Oh, jetzt bin ich aber schnell.
Null Leute sind, äh, ne, doch, sind Leute.
Also laut Twitch sind es nämlich noch genau null Leute, die online sind.
Jetzt sind es zwölf.
Na gut.
So, Boxcamp, wie ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Lul.
So.
Und Leute, habe ich die Woche irgendwas Spannendes verpasst?
War bei euch irgendwas?
Ich überlege gerade was.
Es war Gamescom diese Woche, gell?
Ja, habe ich relativ wenig mitbekommen.
Ich habe nur, ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass...
Boah, habe ich überhaupt was mitbekommen?
Habe ich überhaupt was mitbekommen?
Wahrscheinlich war es genauso langweilig wie immer.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich da nicht mehr hingehe.
Also Gamescom ist ganz nice, wenn man vielleicht Bock hat, mal ein paar Leute zu sehen wieder,
die man online kennt und lange nicht, nicht, nicht oft sieht und so.
Da ist Gamescom gut.
Gamescom ist...
Es ist tatsächlich nicht gut, wenn man sich Spiele angucken will.
Selbst wenn man da im Vorfeld Termine ausmacht.
Dann geht es noch.
Aber wenn man da einfach nur so hinfährt, was ich auch gar nicht, also was ich überhaupt nicht mehr könnte,
da den ganzen Tag rumgammeln, ohne Termine, weil...
Da stehst du zweieinhalb Stunden an, dass du irgendwas angucken kannst.
Das ist halt echt lächerlich.
Du kannst komplett knicken.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so voll wie vor Corona.
Oder müssen wir mal gucken.
Weil vor Corona haben sie ja jedes Jahr neue Zuschauerrekorde vermeldet.
Und das war in Köln eh schon immer viel zu knapp.
Also der Platz, das war so eng und so nervig.
Deswegen bin ich auch schon ein paar Jahre nicht hingefahren.
Habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr.
Ein Presseausweis bringt dir nichts.
Du musst dich am Anfang akkreditieren.
Das musst du im Vorfeld machen.
Dann kannst du dann da hingehen.
Der Trick ist eh, dass man nicht den Haupteingang benutzt,
sondern rechts um die Ecke läuft vom Bahnhof.
Und dann kannst du da dann...
...ein Bändchen abholen.
Zumindest war das früher so.
Ich war jetzt ja schon ein paar Jahre nicht mehr da.
Weißt du noch, wo ich da das erste Mal hin bin?
Also als ich auch schon den YouTube-Channel hatte.
Und ein bisschen was halt über Games berichten wollte.
So von der Gamescom.
Damals haben die noch gesagt,
YouTube-Channel zählt nicht als Akkreditierung.
Du brauchst, du musst für irgendeine Zeitschrift arbeiten.
Und so was.
Aber es ging dann doch, witzigerweise.
Das war noch...
Das ist aber schon wirklich lange her.
Das muss wahrscheinlich 2011 oder 2012 gewesen sein.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile haben die keine Probleme mehr,
dass du dich mit einem ordentlichen YouTube-Channel akkreditieren kannst für die Gamescom.
Ransomware-Angriff, alle Daten bei Cloud Nordic, Futsch.
Wer hat Cloud...
Was läuft da?
Was ist bei Cloud Nordic?
Der Cloud-Dienstleister Cloud Nordic aus Dänemark
wurde am Freitagmorgen Hackraments
eines Ransomware-Angriffes...
Sag ich mal in Lautstärke, okay?
Ich denke schon.
Ich meine, es ist ja Windows, da weiß man das ja nie.
Ja, alles gut.
Der Cloud-Dienstleister Cloud Nordic aus Dänemark
wurde am Freitagmorgen vergangener Woche
Opfer eines Ransomware-Angriffs.
Also das ist Thema bei einer Überprüfung
und externen Angriffen.
Haben sie...
Dass sich keine Daten retten lassen, die dann...
Ja gut, können die ja froh sein, dass nicht alles abgezogen wurde.
Dass nur Sachen verschlüsselt, beziehungsweise
gelöscht wurden.
Die sollen froh sein, dass die nicht irgendwelche Daten abgezogen haben.
Jetzt ist die Webseite komplett down?
Ach nee.
Hm, oh, alles klar.
Tja, Cloud halt.
Die bekleckern sich doch alle nicht mit Ruhm.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch an vor ein, zwei Wochen
das Master-Tool, das sie in der Webseite verwendet haben.
Das Master-Tool, das sie in der Webseite verwendet haben.
Für die Microsoft Cloud.
Da hat Microsoft...
Oder für Azure.
Da hat Microsoft auch nie...
Irgendwas...
Groß...
Das haben die einfach totgeschwiegen.
Hintergründe zum Angriff.
Okay, das ist immer ganz spannend.
Cloud Nordic erklärte, dass bei einem Umzug von Servern
von einem Rechenzentrum in ein anderes
die Maschinen an das interne Netz angeschlossen wurden.
Die Maschinen waren zuvor in getrennten Netzen aktiv.
Auf einigen Servern lauerten trotz Firewalls und Virenscanner
und so weiter.
Und das war das, was sie in der Webseite verwendet haben.
Unerkannte Infektionen.
Ah.
Ja, das ist doof gelaufen.
Mit Linux-Server wäre ihnen das wahrscheinlich nicht passiert.
Ich meine, kann dir selbstverständlich
im Linux-Server theoretisch auch passieren.
Aber praktisch...
Also ehrlich gesagt...
Wie nennt man das?
Das wird ja so eine
Trust-me-Bro-Argumentation.
Aber gibt es da so ein spezielles Wort für?
Aber ich sag's euch jetzt trotzdem.
Also, ich bin jetzt seit 15 Jahren
professionell in der IT tätig.
Erst bei einem Internet-Provider,
dann bei einer Bank,
jetzt bei einer Versicherung.
Ich bin früher regelmäßig,
Turnschuh-mäßig ins Rechenzentrum geflitzt und so.
Und ich habe bisher
nicht einen Linux-Server erlebt,
der sich in ein Virus eingefangen hat.
Aber durchaus schon
sehr viele Windows-Klienten,
sehr viele Windows-Klienten und Windows-Server.
Mein Windows-Klient, obviously.
Da habe ich euch ja mal erzählt,
da hatten wir richtige Probleme,
auch mit Verschlüsselungssachen.
Aber der eigentliche Angriff
damals bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
kam ja über nicht gesicherte Windows-Server.
Letztendlich gemerkt hat man es auf den Windows-Klienten,
aber eingefallen sind die über
einen ungesicherten Windows-Server.
Und insofern...
Ja, Windows, Windows halt.
Unsere Linux-Systeme waren die einzigen Sachen,
die nicht betroffen waren
und mein Linux-Notebook auch nicht.
Das heißt, wir waren die einzigen,
die dort ordentlich arbeiten konnten in der Zeit.
Und helfen konnten,
das alles wieder ordentlich zu machen.
Pato, hey, die Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also, ich habe bisher nur,
ich habe bisher nur Virenbefall,
Ransomware und solche Geschichten mitbekommen
für Windows-Klienten, für Windows-Server.
Nie für Linux-Server und Linux-Systeme.
Wie gesagt, theoretisch kann das natürlich auch passieren,
habe ich aber bisher noch nicht mitbekommen.
Natürlich, wenn du jetzt,
wenn du jetzt einen
Linux, also einen Windows-Share
auf einem Linux-Server betreibst
und sich irgendein
Windows-User,
was einfängt,
was dann anfängt, den gemounteten,
die gemountete Platte zu verschlüsseln,
ja, da würde ich aber nicht so weit gehen
und sagen, das ist ein Virus, den sich der
der Linux-Server eingefangen hat,
also irgendein Windows-Client verschlüsselte Dateien,
wobei man das auch teilweise schon ganz gut ist,
schon ganz gut erkennen kann.
Es gibt da Erkennung so nach dem Motto,
hier schreibt relativ viel random Zeug und sowas,
aber trotzdem ist es natürlich schwierig.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Irgendwelche Linux-Jump-Posts sind sicherlich sinnvoll.
Ich meine, wenn eure komplette Umgebung Windows ist,
da wird es euch ein Linux-Terminal-Server auch nicht bringen.
Außerdem braucht man ja gar keinen Linux-Terminal-Server,
um sich ordentlich über Linux-Tunnel zu können.
Aber so ein SSH-Login dazwischen wirkt, wirkt Wunder.
Natürlich stimme ich dir zu als Linux-Admin,
dass das so ist.
Natürlich sind alle Linux-Admins mehr Pfeife,
als Windows-Admins, da sind wir uns ja einig.
Wie läuft die Lauferei?
Oh, ich bin relativ zackig mittlerweile.
Ich kann es dir sagen, warte mal.
Ich will euch jetzt nicht zu sehr damit vorlabern,
aber gestern erst gelaufen, pass mal auf,
gestern erst, 44 Minuten, 6,1 Kilometer,
durchschnittliche Herzfrequenz 157,
durchschnittlicher Pace 7 Minuten 16 für einen Kilometer.
Ich habe angefangen mit 8 Minuten 30 vor zwei Wochen oder so.
Aber das liegt, glaube ich, jetzt auch daran,
nicht, dass ich so ultra viel fitter jetzt schon geworden bin,
sondern, dass ich mich einfach daran gewöhnt habe
und auch ein bisschen, sag mal,
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen mehr Muskeln habe,
was Wade und so angeht nach zwei Wochen,
sodass das Laufen einfach einfacher fällt.
Ich habe mir jetzt übrigens auch ein paar ordentliche Schuhe gekauft zum Laufen.
Ich bin ja vorher in meinen ganz normalen Turnschuhen gerannt.
Die sind allerdings so gut wie gar nicht,
wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch, abgefedert, glaube ich.
Weiß nicht, so Kaschen.
Die sind halt ziemlich, ziemlich hart von der Sohle her.
Die geben ein bisschen nach, aber halt wirklich nur relativ, relativ starr.
Ich habe mir jetzt ein paar Schuhe gekauft zum Laufen
und ich muss sagen,
das ist was ganz, was anderes.
Das ist viel angenehmer.
Ich habe mir jetzt gekauft,
ich habe mir so richtige fette Laufschuhe gekauft.
Also mit fett meine ich nicht unbedingt den Preis,
der ist auch nicht billig,
sondern fette, fette Polster,
weil ich bin ja auch nicht der Leichteste
und dann ist es eh schon ziemlich anstrengend für Muskeln und Gelenke.
Wie heißt das Ding? So ein Teil.
So ein Teil habe ich mir gekauft.
Barfuß kannst du vergessen.
Guckt mal, ihr müsst euch mal, guckt euch, guckt euch mal,
dieses, dieses Kissen an, was da drunter ist.
Gibt es, gibt es auch in allen möglichen.
Wo ist meiner hier? Das ist meiner.
Ja, ne.
Doch, doch.
Das da.
44.
Das Teil habe ich mir gekauft.
Allerdings,
nicht die Variante, sondern
die gibt es, die gibt es auch in white.
Ich habe mir die in white gekauft, weil andere waren ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen schmal.
Und das da unten ist halt quasi wie so ein Kissen,
was du unten drunter hast.
Und als ich das erste Mal damit gelaufen bin,
muss ich sagen, das war echt ein Riesenunterschied.
Die erste Hälfte meiner Runde hat mich überhaupt nicht gestört.
Normalerweise habe ich das immer direkt gemerkt,
in den Waden, im Oberschenkel und sonst wie,
dass man das halt, das war halt sehr hart aufgetreten.
Ich habe die erste Hälfte der Runde nichts gemerkt.
Das war einfach nur extrem entspannt und angenehm.
Dann war ich zu doof und bin zu schnell weitergegangen.
Weil es so easy lief.
Und war dann übelst fertig nach der Runde.
Aber okay.
So.
Und ein Problem, was ich habe,
aber ich glaube, das liegt an meinen Füßen.
Ein Problem, was ich habe,
ich laufe halt sonst,
also tagsüber und wenn ich renne und so,
nur in relativ harten Turnschuhen.
So im Vergleich zu denen.
Und dementsprechend sind meine Füße
an so weichen Untergrund nicht gewöhnt.
Und ich habe das,
ich habe das die ersten zwei, drei Kilometer
übelst gemerkt,
dass sich mein Fuß voll verkrampft hat
in den neuen Schuhen.
Obwohl der Schuh richtig fest war
und auch von der Größe her gut passt.
Voll verkrampft haben,
weil meine Füße das gar nicht gewohnt sind,
auf ein bisschen, so ein bisschen,
nicht ganz so hartem Untergrund zu stehen, ja.
Aber es ging dann.
Man muss sich einfach nur darauf konzentrieren,
dass man entspannt läuft.
Es geht nicht darum, schnell zu rennen
oder nicht nur darum, schnell zu rennen, sondern,
vor allem, dass das halbwegs schonend
und angenehm ist zu rennen.
Ja.
Pistolen in dieser Farbe habe ich am Start.
Also fühlt sich, fühlt sich mega entspannt an,
da drin zu laufen.
Mr. Essen Alive,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also die ganze Zeit vorher hatte ich,
hatte ich wirklich ziemlich, ziemlich harte Schuhe.
Also da hatte ich irgendwie sowas.
Das sind halt so normale Turnschuhe,
die ich anhabe, ja.
Das sind so die richtigen Boomer Schuhe.
160, gibt es sowas?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt für Schuhe anhabe,
aber welche, die nicht so gut,
nicht so schön gepolstert sind.
Das mag sein, aber zum Rennen, ganz ehrlich,
es ist, es ist einfach mega angenehm gewesen
mit den Schuhen versus den,
also das wirklich super angenehm zu laufen.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen skeptisch,
wie lange das hält.
Laut Reviews, laut Reviews soll das relativ,
relativ lange halten.
Also das wird ja immer so gesagt,
so was, was ich so,
kannst du so viele Kilometer rennen damit,
bis es dann, aber,
also ich habe meine Zweifel,
wie lange das hält,
weil billig sind die Teile nicht.
Wobei, wenn du dir die kaufst,
sind die ein bisschen billiger.
Ich habe, glaube ich, 140 Euro oder so
dafür bezahlt bei Amazon.
Ja, also der offizielle Preis ist ein bisschen pepeger.
Ja, bei Amazon, bei Amazon kostet das Ganze einfach,
60 Euro weniger.
Oder man kauft sich die Damenvariante,
dann ist es noch billiger.
Die sind kleiner.
Ja, guck hier, 150.
Ja gut, Damen kostet ein bisschen mehr.
Die sind billiger bei Amazon.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum, hier und auch hier.
Guck.
Das, das ist mal eine Fifat-Farbe,
hä?
Ja.
Naja.
Und es ist halt wirklich extrem angenehm
versus, versus die anderen Schuhe.
So, aber genug.
Ah ja, ich wollte, ich wollte ja erzählen.
Also, ich bin jetzt, ich bin jetzt,
letztens, also meine aktuelle Rekordrunde ist
7 Minuten, 7 Minuten 16 pro Kilometer.
So, und das sind,
das sind 8,3 Kilometer die Stunde,
die man da, die man da rennt.
So, mal gucken.
Ich werde das weitermachen.
Ich renn weiter, jeden zweiten Tag.
Ich muss sagen, mir macht das richtig Spaß mittlerweile.
Und ich mache ja auch noch meine normale Runde.
Also, ich laufe meine, meine sechs Kilometer alle zwei Tage
und dann gehe ich meine eineinhalb, zwei Stunden
nachmittags ja noch meine Wanderrunde machen.
Und da habe ich genug, genug Kalorienverbrauch
und auch genug Bewegung.
Also, ich hatte gestern,
ich hatte gestern, gestern die beiden Runden zusammen
waren über, also zumindest, zumindest hat das mein Fitness,
meine Fitness-Tracker-Geschichte ausgerechnet.
Ich habe, ich habe so eine, so eine Uhr, die das misst,
was du für eine Pulsfrequenz und so hast,
hatte ich mit beiden Runden zusammen,
also mittags, mittags sechs Kilometer rennen
oder 6,1 Kilometer rennen
und morgens, ich glaube, 7,8 Kilometer wandern durch den Wald,
habe ich über 1000 Kalorien verbraucht.
Das ist fast ein Drittel oder so vom, vom, vom Tagesbedarf.
Also, das ist schon ordentlich.
Da muss man, muss man ordentlich,
muss man ordentlich fressen,
dass ich mein Gewicht halte.
Dafür habe ich mittags auch krass viel gefressen, Alter.
Ich habe nur, ich habe Nudeln, nicht mit Lachs, Leute,
einfach nur Nudeln mit, mit Hackfleisch.
So, und ich muss euch das jetzt mal zeigen.
Also, es gibt genau, so, du hast ja,
es gibt ja einmal Sodteller und es gibt,
und es gibt Sodteller, ja.
Und da ist logischerweise viel mehr Platz drin,
weil bei gleicher Größe hat so ein Teller halt nur hier so was,
so, so ein bisschen.
Und so ein Teller hat halt die komplette Fläche.
So, und ich habe drei Teller, so Teller voll,
also nicht gehäuft, aber voll mit Nudeln gefressen,
gestern Mittag, weil ich so übertrieben Hunger hatte
nach der ganzen Geschichte.
Naja, ich habe mehr Tagesbedarf.
Ich bin, ich bin dick.
Ich habe, also in meiner Wander-,
in meiner, in meiner Fitness-Tracker-App habe ich eingegeben,
93 Kilo.
Stimmt nicht so ganz, es ist so im Durchschnitt,
mal mehr, mal weniger.
Morgens nach dem Aufstehen sind es meistens 92,
dafür sind es abends dann, wenn ich, da sind drei,
also, ich, ich, ich habe eher, ich habe 93 mal eingegeben.
Und da verbraucht man ja allgemein mehr,
wenn man dick ist.
Wobei, so dick bin ich gar nicht mehr.
Also, vor, vor zwei Jahren war ich mit 100,
108,5, 109, 108, ja, so irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Und eine ganze Ecke dicker.
Ja, warum, nicht, kein flacher Teller.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ich meine keinen flachen Teller, guck mal.
Es gibt, es gibt Teller, die haben so einen Rand, so.
Und dann gibt es Teller, die sind genauso groß,
haben aber hier keinen Rand, sondern gehen einfach runter.
Also nicht flach, sondern so was hier, so was hier.
Guck.
Also, also ein Teller, der quasi so groß ist wie der,
nur dass er hier direkt runter geht,
dass der quasi dann nochmal so ein Drittel extra Fläche hat, so.
Und davon habe ich drei, drei voll mit Nudeln gefressen, ja.
Da sind die Kalorien wieder drin.
Die haben keinen Griff, nö, brauchst du ja auch nicht.
Das steht ja auch vor mir und dann geht's
reingestopft, Alter.
Nee, aber so einen flachen Teller kannst du ja nicht essen,
da fallen ja die Nudeln die ganze Zeit raus.
Und Klecker ist so die Sauce,
Zagfleisch und Tomatensauce auf den Tisch.
Nee.
Die haben keinen Griff.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist, das ist eher was, im Restaurant möchte ich halt auch nicht servieren müssen
mit, mit so einem Teller hier.
Naja.
Wie dem auch sei.
Lejak, danke schön für den Sub.
Das ist tatsächlich eher so eine Art Schüssel.
Ja, ich hatte übertrieben Hunger.
Ganz ehrlich?
Das habe ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt.
Das, ich, ich hab, ich hab's noch nicht geguckt.
Ich, ich hab, ich hab's noch nicht gemacht, aber das habe ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt.
Warum nehme ich überhaupt noch einen Teller?
Ich meine, ich könnte einfach Nudeln kochen,
dann, ähm, in, in der Pfanne Hackfleisch, Tomatensauce und am Ende
kippe ich einfach das Hackfleisch und die Tomatensauce in die Schüssel,
äh, nicht in die Schüssel, in den, in den Topf, wo die Nudeln drin waren, rühre um und esse was da draus.
Also, das müsste eigentlich sogar mein, am allereinfachsten sein.
Und ich hätte eine Portion auf einmal, müsste nicht zwischendurch, zwischendurch was holen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ziemlich Sixthead, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Musst weniger sauber machen.
Du verbrauchst weniger Wasser.
Und dann sparst du Geld, ja.
Und du musst zwischendurch nicht aufstehen und dir neues Zeug holen.
Und es wird, es, es ist nicht dann eine Sache kälter als die andere und so.
Das ist eigentlich super.
Das ist eigentlich, eigentlich ist es extrem Sixthead.
Die Nudeln direkt aus dem, das einzige, wo das nicht so Sixthead ist,
wenn du zu viel gemacht hast, dass du es nicht alles packst.
Hehe.
Excellent.
Wir, wir waren aber eigentlich noch beim Hackerangriff auf die Dänen hier.
Was kam denn jetzt da raus?
Also, Windows, Windows-Systeme
hatten, haben, haben ihr, ihr Verschlüsselungstrojaner-Zeug verteilt.
The Real Agent Smith ist am Start.
Bei deinem Namen fällt mir auf, ich muss unbedingt mal wieder Matrix 1 gucken.
Ich sag absichtlich 1, weil alle anderen Filme naja sind.
Ich muss den so alle 2, 3 Jahre mal gucken.
Das ist einer meiner absolut Lieblingsfilme.
Besser.
Dadurch gelang es den Cyberkrimi...
Ich find dieses Wort so geil immer auf Deutsch.
Cyberkrimi...
Kriminalität.
Dadurch gelang es den...
Gottes Abbild.
Prime ist abgelaufen.
Ja, ich war ne Weile nicht online jetzt, die letzten schon 5 Tage her.
Da kann man das schon mal vergessen, seh ich auch so.
Aber danke für den Sub.
Ne, also, ernsthaft.
Ich, ich weiß, dass ich die letzten, letzten Wochen nicht so oft online war.
Liegt aber einfach da dran.
Erstens ist es auf der Arbeit recht anstrengend.
Außerdem spiel ich nebenbei Baldur's Gate 3.
Und außerdem bewege ich mich jetzt so auch noch mehr.
Also das ist tatsächlich...
Und, und ich will noch ein bisschen Broggers Zeug privat für mich machen.
Also sprich...
Schwierig.
Äh, falsches Emote.
Ähm, grad dann auch noch paar Stunden zu streamen.
Aber, das wird sich auch wieder tun.
Spätestens, Leute, spätestens im Dezember gibt's wieder komplette Content Offensive.
Da bin ich den ganzen Dezember frei.
Aber...
Das, äh, muss ich irgendwie mal gucken, dass ich das alles auf die Reihe kriege.
Und ich muss ein Video aufnehmen.
Ich hab schon ein Thema.
Und ich hab mir sogar schon ein paar Sachen so aufgeschrieben.
Vielleicht mach ich das nach dem Stream gleich.
So.
Also, Windows...
Infizierte Windows Server...
Dadurch gelang den Cyberkriminellen der Zugriff auf alle Datenspeicher, Replikations-Backup-Systeme und sekundäre Sicherungssysteme.
Okay.
Die bösartigen Akteure verschissen alle Server-Laufwerke, die primären und die sekundären Backup-
Da stürzten die Rechner ab und halten die Akteure ab.
Und hatten keinen Zugriff mehr auf Daten.
Nein.
Datenschutzverstoß etwa nur.
Hab ich nicht festgestellt.
Tja.
Pech gehabt.
Nicht aufgepasst.
Aber letztendlich...
Passieren kann immer irgendwas.
Hat man ja letztens wieder bei Microsoft gesehen, die einfach einen ihrer zentralen Tokens verloren haben und da nichts dazu gesagt haben.
Ach ja, das ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Ist ja nichts passiert.
Ja, aber Microsoft, äh, wir wissen doch gar nicht, ob nichts passiert ist.
Ne, ne, glaubt uns mal.
Ist ja nichts passiert.
Ja, aber Microsoft, äh, wir wissen doch gar nicht, ob nichts passiert ist.
Ne, ne, glaubt uns mal.
Ist ja nichts passiert.
Alles gut.
Lumiko.
1337 Elite.
Hier am Start.
Danke für den Sub.
So.
Dann lasst uns mal schnell...
Ja, du meinst den hier.
Das hatten wir doch gerade.
Cloud Nordic.
So.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schnell...
Ach nee, hier ist nichts Trending.
Ich explodiere.
Ja.
Backups und so verschlüsselt waren, aber
aufgefallen ist es, haltet euch mal
fest, aufgefallen, dass
irgendwas nicht stimmt, bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich
euch das schon mal erzählt habe, also bei
meinem alten Arbeitgeber aufgefallen,
dass es dort irgendwie so ein kleines
Viren-Trojaner
Malware-Problem gibt
im Windows-Sektor, ist aufgefallen,
weil, jetzt haltet euch fest,
jemand hat auf dem Windows-Laufwerk
seine entschlüsselten Keypass-Safe
als Textdatei gefunden.
Und da hat er sich gedacht,
da hat er sich gedacht, Moment,
warum ist mein Keypass
entschlüsselt auf dem Netzlaufwerk in plaintext?
Und daraufhin
haben sie angefangen mal zu suchen, was da
los ist, und es ist aufgefallen,
oh shit, es gibt
noch deutlich mehr Probleme.
Gab es sonst keine Alerts? Nein,
nix, bis dahin nicht aufgefallen.
So, ähm,
und,
ja, die Details
will ich jetzt nicht so erzählen, aber
ich kann euch erzählen, woher
es, woher es gekommen ist. Woher es gekommen ist.
Und zwar, ich hoffe, ich krieg das noch
halbwegs richtig zusammen. Und zwar
war die Einfalls...
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Wobei, jetzt, jetzt auch nicht mehr. Das war aber
eine Zeit lang so.
Zumindest.
Ey, gut, du musst ja immer noch irgendwas einfangen,
irgendwas, was einfangen,
was den RAM ausliest,
ne, so einfach, nur weil die im RAM liegen,
landen die nicht auf einer Textdatei im Windows-Share.
Ich mein, der Chat ist auch frei lesbar
und landet nicht bei mir,
in der Textdatei auf dem Windows-Share.
Hoffe ich zumindest.
Vielleicht ist ja mein Windows, mein, mein
Share inoffizieller Twitch-Backup-Server.
So, also, ich kann euch aber
erzählen, wo es hergekommen ist, wo das Einfallstor war.
Und zwar,
wir hatten, sie hatten einen
SCP, genau, so war das.
Sie hatten einen SCP-Server,
also,
wurde dich, wurde per
SSH und SCP-Sachen
drauf kopieren.
Sie hatten einen SCP-Server,
also einen Dateiaustausch-Server
bereitgestellt
für einen Dienstleister.
Allerdings sind sie auf die
chlorreiche Idee gekommen, und jetzt haltet euch fest,
sie sind auf die chlorreiche Idee gekommen,
den
Dateiaustausch-Server, wo die Leute
per SCP drauf kopiert haben,
unter Windows zu betreiben, nicht unter Linux.
Und das war schon das erste Problem.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man überhaupt
irgendwas für SSH-Logins unter Windows betreibt,
aber gut.
Es war ein oller Windows-Server,
mit irgendeinem SCP-Server,
frag mich nicht,
was benutzt man denn,
was gibt's denn da unter Windows überhaupt?
Oh nein,
im Zweifelsfall war das bestimmt auch noch
SolarWills.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, aber das wird
natürlich passen, Alter.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich
brauchst du das gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich brauchst du das gar nicht,
weil du hast ja unter Windows,
achso,
wobei, hast du da ein SSHD mittlerweile drauf?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Zumindest war es ein SCP-Server,
wo du dich einloggen konntest.
Und das war ein oller Windows,
ein oller, ein oller SCP-Server.
Und da waren irgendwelche
Hackermans, waren beim Dienstleister
aktiv und die haben dann halt vom Dienstleister
ausgeguckt, wo sie hinkommen können.
Haben dann das Einfallstor über diesen
nicht richtig gesicherten SCP-Server
gefunden. Und
das nächste bin ich mir nicht so sicher, dass ich das nicht so sicher habe.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher.
Es kann auch sein, dass jetzt ein bisschen Mist ist, was ich erzähle.
Zumindest hatten sie irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
dann ihre Berechtigung da drauf zu
eskalieren.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Es hat mir mal einer erzählt,
das war relativ easy.
Also entweder lief der SCP
der SCP-User
unter einem Admin-Account
oder es war irgendwie eine andere
Software drauf, die unter einem Admin-Account
lief oder ein alter
irgendwie ein temporäres
Service.
Also es war irgendwie eine Version von einem Admin-Account.
Irgendwas. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ich habe es mir auch nicht
genau gemerkt.
Zumindest hatten sie einen Admin-Account
relativ schnell, einen Admin-Account für das ganze
Active Directory. Und dann
haben sie über die Software-Verteilung vom
Active Directory
Keylogger und
Keypass
Passwort-Dumper
und so Zeug installiert.
Und dann hat irgendjemand sein Windows
sein Keypass-Dump auf dem Windows-Share
gefunden.
Wir wissen nicht genau oder wussten damals
nicht genau, wie lange die schon aktiv waren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht so lang, aber bestimmt
schon zwei, drei Tage. Also im Zweifelsfall
hätten die auch genug Zeit gehabt,
sehr viel abzusaugen. Allerdings
hatte mein alter Arbeitgeber da relativ
Glück im Unglück.
Denn
die Hackermans
haben das wohl gar nicht so richtig
realisiert, wo sie da gelandet sind.
Und
haben
das wohl auch nur
automatisiert.
Halt alles laufen lassen, ohne genauer zu gucken.
Also es wurde höchstwahrscheinlich nichts groß an Daten abgezogen.
Es wurde auch nicht versucht, sich auf unsere Linux-Systeme und Datenbanken Zugriff zu verschaffen.
Das ist rein auf Windows und hauptsächlich Client-Systemen gewesen.
Ja, und angeblich, angeblich haben sie die auch erwischt.
Hat man dann so ein halbes Jahr später gehört, die Hackermans.
Ja, so sah das aus.
Also da war richtig die Kacke am Dampfen, kann ich euch sagen.
Und wisst ihr, was gut war?
Dass
einzig und allein unsere
Linux-Laptops sicher waren
und unsere
Linux-Server sicher waren.
Das waren die einzigen Systeme, wo wir
davon ausgehen konnten, da ist nichts passiert.
Und das ging so weit,
das war witzig, das war echt lustig
mal zu sehen, weil die ganzen
Leute da
eher ein bisschen Linux-feindlich fast
schon eingestellt waren.
So nach dem Motto, wie ihr habt Linux-Notebooks,
das ist ja gar nicht im AD, das ist ja
voll unsicher. Und jedes Mal,
wenn das einer gesagt hat, habe ich dann nur noch
zu ihm gesagt,
nach dem Vorfall.
Und
das war
insofern witzig, weil die ganzen
Leute, die dort dann, das ging ja über das
Wochenende, ja, die ganzen Leute, die dort
dann über das Wochenende auch
aktiv waren, das alles wieder mit gefixt haben,
die haben sich dann,
von uns, Ubuntu-USB-Sticks
geholt und haben damit ihr Notebook
gebootet.
Die gleichen Leute,
die vorher auch immer ein bisschen erzählt haben, so
Linux-unsicher, weil nicht am Active Directory
angebunden, null.
Ach ja, und wisst ihr,
was das Beste ist?
Das Beste, ähm,
ja, also, wisst ihr, was
das Beste ist, aus dieser
ganzen Story, das Fazit daraus?
Wisst ihr, übrigens war auch
eines der Gründe, warum ich,
noch weniger Bock hatte, dort zu bleiben, weil ich
es total dämlich fand, und
das konnte ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Also, wisst ihr, was die
Management-Entscheidung daraufhin war?
Nachdem über
Windows-Sachen eingebrochen wurde?
Wisst ihr, was die Management-Entscheidung
gewesen ist, daraufhin?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ganz so, ganz,
nein, nein, nein, nein, die Management-Entscheidung
darauf, danach war,
wir installieren jetzt
auf allen unseren Systemen
Windows Defender,
auf,
auch, auf Linux.
Also, wer das nicht weiß, es gibt
Windows Defender
für Linux. Also,
gibt es, ja,
also, wer denkt, das gibt es, das gibt es.
Das benutzt
keine Sau, aber das gibt es.
Daniel Lull, danke schön
für den Sub, das gibt es.
Und das musste dann,
das musste dann auf allen Linux-Systemen
und Linux-Servern installiert werden.
Und,
wir sollten das dann auch auf unseren
Linux-Notebooks installieren.
So, das wollte ich aber nicht.
Weil es mich übelst
abgefuckt hat, ja.
Und ich habe das dann einfach zwei Wochen
oder so ausgesessen und da hat sich nie jemand
wieder drum gekümmert, ob ich es installiert habe oder nicht.
Ja, das musste dann auf jeden
Windows-Server installiert werden.
Und er hat regelmäßig Probleme gemacht.
Unter Linux.
Also, das Ding,
das Ding hat regelmäßig hohe CPU-Last
verursacht.
Und teilweise auch, dass es nicht so gut ist.
Ich habe auf E-Mail-Systemen den Dateizugriff
ultra langsam gemacht.
Ja.
Und eines der Probleme war,
und das sollte jeder wissen, der
Microsoft Defender für Linux, also auf Linux
betreibt,
Microsoft kann den Windows Defender
ungefragt updaten,
solange das System über ein Proxy
irgendwie zu den Microsoft-Servern kommt.
Also, das mag
der ein oder andere gut finden,
weil es immer aktuelle Virensignaturen hat,
aber Microsoft updatet darüber nicht nur die
Virensignaturen, Microsoft
updatet darüber auch Sachen im
Windows Defender selbst.
Also, es kann sein, dass von heute
auf morgen auf einmal Linux-Systeme,
die komplett unauffällig waren,
bei euch auf einmal 80% CPU-Last
haben und es kommt dann raus,
ah, Microsoft hat nicht nur die Virensignaturen
geupdatet, sondern auch einen Patch
eingespielt für Windows Defender.
Und es ist natürlich sinnvoll, dass du die Systeme
rauslässt zu den Microsoft-Servern,
dass sie sich Virensignaturen ziehen können.
Also,
echt hochgradig fragwürdiger
Shit, warum man das auf Windows-Systemen installiert.
Äh, nicht nur,
warte mal, nicht nur das,
die gleichen
doch auch, stand das mit,
die suchen Passwörter aus E-Mail-
Verläufen raus
und vergleichen das nicht auch mit irgendeiner Standard-Passwort-Liste
ab und sowas.
Richtig, richtig hängengeblieben.
So, aber lasst uns mal kurz gucken,
was trendet auf Shithub.
AI,
AI, AI,
ne,
Moment,
ein MMO
in Rust,
ah, ne,
React,
WebAssembly oder doch Rust,
Rust,
Leute,
ah, es ist so eine Art
MMO-Minecraft
mit,
auf Rust-Basis.
Next.js-Typescript-React-WebAssembly,
aha,
was ist das?
China, China-Chinesen-Zeug?
Oh, shit,
was bin ich hier sehend?
What the fuck?
Moment,
hat man das dann auf dem Desktop oder wie?
Alles klar?
Alles klar, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Ja,
kein Wunder, dass das 2.4.000 Sterne hat.
Hey, AI,
Terraform-Shit, ja,
weil HashiCorp gesagt hat,
die neuen Terraform-Versionen sind jetzt,
ähm,
ne, nicht Closed-Source,
sondern sind jetzt irgendwie
eingeschränkt,
dass man ihnen nicht mehr damit Konkurrenz machen kann
oder sowas,
weil ich das vielleicht ein bisschen überreagiert finde,
da was zu forken
oder was das auch immer ist.
Ach, ne, das ist bloß,
irgendjemand hat einen Text geschrieben,
warum das eine doofe Idee ist.
AI, AI, AI, AI,
Flutter, dum, dum, dum,
AI, AI,
äh, nicht so spannend.
Gucken wir mal, was sich hier getan hat.
AI,
AI, Avalonia,
naja,
okay,
ups,
nicht so spannend.
Ah, ja, ja.
Hast du schon mal im Stream was mit HTMX gemacht?
Ne, wollen wir das machen?
Können wir machen, ich mein,
wir gucken uns ja öfters neues Zeug an.
Ich kenn das, ich hab da letztens sogar irgendwo ein Video drüber geguckt,
AI Power Tools vor HTML.
Ach, die Geschichte war das.
Ja, doch, doch.
Können wir uns, können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Das haben wir schon gemacht.
Auch gemacht haben wir.
Avalonia hatten wir uns doch auch angeguckt.
Das war doch ganz okay.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ne, Power, oh, Power, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Hat denn einer von euch schon mal was mit HTMX gemacht?
Chatge.
Beifährt Chatge.
Bis jetzt bin ich noch ein bisschen unschlüssig,
wann und wozu man das benutzen sollte,
aber werden wir ja dann sehen.
Ich find den Namen ein bisschen unglücklich, ja.
Go.
Okay, lass mal gucken, was, was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube?
Die absurde Welt der nordkoreanischen Influence.
Oh, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Oh, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Oh, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Nordkoreanischen Influence.
Oh, Simplicissimus, da hab ich jetzt keinen Nerv drauf.
Immer.
Sind keine schlechten Videos, das ist aber meistens so,
das hört sich alles, jeder Satz
hört sich da immer so unglaublich wichtig
ausgesprochen an, da brauch ich, muss ich mir erstmal
ein paar andere Videos geben für euch,
bevor ich mir das
anhören kann.
Was ist das?
Discord Employees Review Working at Discord.
Ne.
Die 10 besten Shooter aller Zeiten.
Ne, wenn da Half-Life 1 nicht vorne dabei ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
China-Schrott, was taugt an 80 Euro
10 Gigabit Switch?
Oh, schreck mich nicht so.
Die Deutsche Bahn macht auf dicke
Hose im Internet.
Oh.
FireShip, FireShip ist auch immer nice.
Was hat CT, was hat die CT
wieder am Start? Der erste Videocall
war schon 1927, ernsthaft?
1927,
das war vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man dort überhaupt schon Video aufnehmen
konnte. Hat da irgendjemand
Fotos geschossen und die
mit einem
Frame pro Tag weiter verschickt?
Oder wie?
Wie soll ein 1927 Videocall ausgesehen haben, Alter?
Foto bei Brieftaube.
Ok, kommen wir uns mal an.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Guck mal hier, so sah ein Videotelefonat
1936 aus.
Das ist die in Nazi-Deutschland
gebaute sogenannte
Fernsehsprechstelle.
Ok, Deutscher kann sich das Ganze aber nicht mehr
anhören, oder?
Guck mal hier, so sah ein
Videotelefonat 1936 aus.
Naja, das ist doch gar nicht
mal so übel, oder?
Ich meine, guck mal,
es scheint ein halbwegs
live Bild zu sein.
Also für 1936
erscheint mir das gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine, alles rein analoge
Übertragungstechnik hat wahrscheinlich
gerauscht, es war eine niedrige Auflösung.
Vielleicht,
es ist doch einfach nur irgendwie
Nazi-Propaganda und das ist ein Foto
und gar kein
bewegtes Bild. Man weiß es ja nicht.
Aber,
also wenn das so funktioniert hat,
why not?
Ich meine, Telefon hat damals auf jeden Fall funktioniert.
Und Kameras
gab es damals
wahrscheinlich auch schon.
Gab es damals Bildschirme?
Ja, klar, ich meine, es gab
Schwarz-Weiß-Filme und so.
Auch, äh,
Geschichte
Fernseh...
ab 1950
dann zum Massenmedium.
Ja, ja, das gab es schon.
Das war aber alles noch relativ neu.
Aber, ich meine, für 1936?
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist die in Nazi-Deutschland
gebaute sogenannte Fernsehsprechstelle.
Der Name ist halt so,
in Deutschland kann es nicht mehr heißen.
Fernsehsprechstelle.
Die Verbreitung dieses Geräts
ist den Nazis ebenso wenig gelungen
wie der Rest ihrer Ideen.
Das war wahrscheinlich...
Also, dass das sich damals nicht verbreitet hat,
lag wahrscheinlich auch schlicht und ergreifend am Preis
und an der nicht vorhandenen
Infrastruktur dafür.
... fast täglich mit Teams,
Zoom, Facetime, Skype,
BigBlueButton oder sonst was in meinen...
BigBlueButton? Hatte jemand schon mal die Ehre
BigBlueButton verwenden zu müssen?
BigBlueButton.
Ja? Wie ist, wie ist
das so?
Ich kenne das immer nur von Screenshots
oder von irgendwelchen Leuten, die darüber ablästern.
Wir hatten BigBlueButton an der Berufsschule.
Absolut kacke.
Okay, das reiht sich
ungefähr in die Berichte ein, die ich auch immer
gehört habe, dass das halt Schrott sein muss.
Ich würde mich halt interessieren, warum das
besser als Zoom...
Ja, Zoom finde ich auch ganz grenzwertig.
Wobei, ich finde,
Zoom geht irgendwie noch.
Ich würde mich letztens auf der Arbeit mal in einen Zoom-Call
joinen, mit dem Browser,
weil irgendein Dienstleister uns was
anpreisen wollte.
Und das war ein Zoom-Call.
Das ging eigentlich recht
gut klar.
Ist BigBlueButton self-hosted?
Kann man das selbst hosten?
Ja, wobei hat da gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben, ne?
Ist das
Open Source auf GitHub?
Shithub?
Complete Open Source Web Conferencing System.
Na, das ist doch auf jeden Fall
schon mal ein Pluspunkt dafür.
Auf was basiert das denn?
Auf was basiert
denn das im Backend?
Bestimmt Java oder sowas.
Äh...
Hä?
Server? Ne.
Äh... Hä?
Ja, auf
was basiert das denn im Backend?
Java wahrscheinlich, hä?
Das ist ja eine wilde Mischung, Alter.
Javascript, Scala, Ruby,
TypeScript, bisschen Bash
und Others.
Ruby!
Das sieht eher wie was aus, wo du keinen Durchblick hast,
wie du es gescheit installieren sollst.
Okay, gucken wir uns doch mal das Video fertig an.
Kamera. Videotelefonie
ist heute allgegenwärtig, aber die
Entwicklung hat fast 100 Jahre gedauert.
Aber, seriously.
Videotelefonie ist heute allgegenwärtig,
aber die Entwicklung... So flüssig,
in so guter Qualität
ist bei den wenigsten Videokonferenzen,
die es mittlerweile.
Also die meisten Leute haben irgendeine miese Webcam,
miese Beleuchtung, 5 FPS
und ihr Mikrofon im Pobbes stecken.
Also, das kann gut
sein, ja.
Aber, also gerade auch
Teams, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Teams
überhaupt 50, 60 oder
60 FPS Videostreams
übertragen kann.
Hat fast 100 Jahre gedauert.
Hier, das ist aus dem Jahr 1927.
Ein Testanruf zwischen Washington und New York.
Und zwei Jahre später auf dem IFA-Vorgänger
in Berlin wurde auch mit BILD telefoniert.
Allerdings nur mit einem Abstand von
wenigen Metern. Ja, und ein paar Jahre später
hat dann die Reichspost in Deutschland die
Fernsehsprechstelle auf den Markt gebracht.
Und damit die weltweit ersten Videotelefone
für... Ist das...
Ist das Vorgänger von der Telekom?
...für die Allgemeinheit.
Also hätte eure Uroma damals schon Facetimen
können? Ja, im Prinzip ja.
1936 gab es schon...
BigBlueButtonOrg, okay.
Lass mal kurz gucken. Wobei, wenn ich da
auf Demo klicke, wird bestimmt meine IP oder so
angezeigt. Sekunde, das wollte ich gerade mal auf
dem zweiten Bildschirm ausprobieren.
Demo. Ey, der Demo-Button geht
bei mir nicht.
Ach, jetzt schon.
Sign up, sign in. Ne,
können wir nicht.
Deine IP habt ihr schon.
Okay, Chat. Da stand gerade
not secure.
Warum gehen die HTTPS?
Jetzt ist es secure.
Die haben keinen Redirect auf HTTPS.
Cringe.
Wer hat dann sowas nicht?
...Verbindung zwischen
großen deutschen Städten und die waren zwar
teuer, aber tatsächlich für alle benutzbar.
Nur war das vor allem Propaganda
und nie wirklich als
Massenkommunikationsmedium gedacht.
Bis es das wurde, hat es noch ein paar Jahrzehnte
und eine Pandemie gebraucht.
Wir schauen uns heute mal an, wie das damals...
Na gut, ich weiß nicht, ob man das Propaganda nennen kann.
Es wird ja oft neue Technik
angepriesen als
ja, kommt
nächstes Jahr und dann dauert es noch 15 Jahre.
Ich meine,
überlegt euch mal, wie oft
wurde jetzt erzählt,
das Ja des Linux-Desktops...
Ups, falscher Kopf.
Wie oft wurde erzählt, das Ja des
Linux-Desktops oder
oder
VR-Brillen und sowas
ist jetzt Mainstream und so.
Das ist bis jetzt auch noch nicht passiert.
...funktioniert hat und wie es dann
ab den 70er Jahren weiter ging mit dem
Thema Videotelefon.
Es wurde für Propaganda...
Gut, dann ist es so ähnlich, wie wenn Nordkorea
irgendwie zeigt...
Hatten sie nicht letztens...
Hatte nicht Nordkorea letztens irgend so einen...
Was war denn... Nee, nee, nee, nicht
Nordkorea. Der Irak.
Der Irak hatte doch letztens so ein
Spezial...
So ein super Spezialchip gezeigt,
der aus irgendwelchen billig China-Chinesen
Teilen bestanden hat. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was
das war. Oder Iran, ja?
Was war das nochmal?
Weiß das noch einer von euch? Was war das denn?
Die haben irgendwas...
Irgendwas gezeigt,
wo sie...
Was angeblich super bahnbrechend war und
es war es halt dann auch nicht, wie vermutet.
Quantencomputer,
irgendwie sowas. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Wo wusste man eigentlich das...
Übrigens, so Telefone in der Richtung,
also jetzt mal
ohne
Videokonferenzgedöns, ja?
Aber Telefone in der Richtung damals
war ich voll
begeistert von, so in dem Dreh
1997. Da gab es dann ISDN.
Und ich fand, ich dachte, ich dachte damals
ISDN ist die Zukunft.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
1997 hat man das gedacht.
Aber kurz darauf
gab es dann DSL, weil
man ja festgestellt hat, dass ISDN
ja eine coole Sache für Telekommunikation
ist, aber mega schlecht für Internet.
ISDN war überhaupt nicht für Internet ausgelegt.
Man konnte es darüber natürlich Datenübertragung machen.
Ja? Aber halt,
ISDN war nicht auf Geschwindigkeit ausgelegt.
Oder auf Bandbreite ausgelegt.
Und
ich hätte damals
ganz im Ernst nicht gedacht,
also hätte mich
1997 jemand gefragt,
hätte ich garantiert nicht gesagt,
dass
analoge Telefonie
länger überlebt als
ISDN.
Wobei man ja Fairness halber sagen muss,
es ist ja eh ganz anders gekommen, als man
damals gedacht hat.
Es sieht ja nur noch aus,
nach analoger Telefonie.
Es ist ja gar keine analoge Telefonie mehr.
Also damals so ein ISDN Telefon,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt,
sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein RJ45 Stecker.
Wobei, wenn ihr mich fragt,
das ist ein RJ45 Stecker.
Ja.
ISDN Kabel, das war ein RJ45 Stecker.
Ne, ne, ne, die normalen Telefone
sind etwas schmaler.
Die ISDN Stecker waren RJ45 Stecker.
Relativ sicher, ja.
Also normaler, analoger
und das ist ein ISDN.
So und
heute benutzt du ja wieder
die analogen Telefonstecker von früher,
nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass es halt spätestens
beim Provider
e-VoIP ist
und höchstwahrscheinlich schon ab deiner Fritzbox aus
oder ab deinem Router aus VoIP ist.
Also insofern,
ja, die letzten paar Meter
sind analoge
Uralt-Technik,
aber trotzdem, ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass das sich länger hält
als ISDN für Festnetzgeräte.
Aber ist so.
Damals hat man,
heute kannst du ISDN Festnetzgeräte
gar nicht mehr anschließen.
Damals hast du noch einen NTBA
gebraucht, hieß der,
NTBA?
Ja, so ein Teil hast du damals noch gebraucht
und das war, genau,
so einen Setup hast du damals gebraucht.
Du musstest hier
in deinen Hausanschluss,
das ist ganz wichtig bei der Telekom immer,
die erste TAE-Dose,
das kann auch sein, dass hier mal ein Telekom-Techniker danach fragt,
hast du dann hier angeschlossen,
du konntest
das auch hier drauf klemmen, wenn du wolltest
und man konnte, und das ist übrigens
ein blödsinniges Bild, normalerweise
hast du dein ISDN hier nebendran
gestöpselt oder halt, ja ok, wenn du
intern das verlängern wolltest.
Das coole bei ISDN war, ich glaube,
du konntest bei ISDN ja theoretisch bis zu
8 Geräte oder sowas anschließen.
Die meisten hatten nur 2, weil
es halt der NTBA-Zweistecke hatte
und richtig abenteuerlich wurde
das ganze Setup dann mit DSL und
einem Splitter dabei, dann sah
das nämlich so aus.
Das, das,
für mich ist das noch das normalste
der Welt, viele Leute kennen das
heute gar nicht mehr.
Ja, du
hast den Splitter
eingestöpselt in deine
TAE-Dose, das ist da, wo früher analog ist,
wo das Telefon dran war.
In den Splitter kam dann auf der einen Seite,
hier vorne, kam der NTBA rein,
hier unten kam dann DSL-Modem rein
und was das gemacht hat,
das hat die Frequenzen
quasi gesplittet.
Das fragt mich nicht, ich glaube,
der untere Frequenzbereich war für ISDN
und das obere Frequenzbereich
war für DSL
und der hat das aufgeteilt, hier zu DSL
und da zu NTBA und hier ist dann dann ISDN
angeschlossen. Also damals war Telefonie
und Internet
tatsächlich noch komplett getrennt
und ISDN hatte ja auch quasi
komplett eigene Telefoniefunktionen
so mit Anrufweiterleitung,
Anrufhalten, Konferenzschaltung
und so, das was heute jeder mit irgendwelchen
VoIP-Clients oder Teams oder so macht,
war ja vieles in ISDN schon eingebaut
und ich hab damals halt echt gedacht,
ISDN ist halt voll der krasse Shit
und sogar in der Berufsschule,
sogar in der Berufsschule
gab es noch ein bisschen was über ISDN
zu hören, allerdings
nicht viel danach wollte die
Telekom ja gar kein ISDN mehr verkaufen
also ich glaube so
ab 2012
13 oder so, na gut das ist doch schon
eine ganze Weile nach der Berufsschule gewesen dann
hat die Telekom ja gesagt
sie wollen kein ISDN mehr verkaufen
und mittlerweile kannst du glaube ich gar kein ISDN
mehr, ISDN Telefon
äh, gibt es
überhaupt noch, macht irgendjemand
das ist doch bestimmt kein echtes
ISDN mehr oder?
Das ist doch auch VoIP mit irgendeiner Box
ja das ist irgendeine Box
wo du ISDN anschließen kannst
aber dahinter ist das ganz normale VoIP
ja
ja das gibt es noch, ja Boxen, du kriegst ja auch heute noch
Fritzboxen mit ISDN Anschlüssen und sowas
ja
so hast du damals
so hast du damals dein
Home Setup
angeschlossen
ja und wenn du kein ISDN hattest
äh Leute
wer weiß es noch, wo hast du hier dein
Telefon angeschlossen, wenn du kein ISDN
hattest, aber wieso
wolltest du heute noch
weiß ich auch nicht
an den Splitter, richtig
dein Telefon hast du da vorne reingesteckt
wenn du kein ISDN hattest
äh
warum man das heute machen sollte, keine Ahnung
ja und ich dachte halt
das war richtig, richtig moderner Shit damals
ich hätte, also hätte
1997 hätte ich im Leben nicht gedacht
dass es mal, dass analoge
Telefonie, sagen wir mal, länger überlebt als
ISDN, wirklich analog ist es ja
heute auch nicht mehr, aber so
die letzten, die letzten paar Meter
wenn man ein Festnetztelefon hat
die letzten paar Meter Kabel
bei manchen kommt ja noch Deck dahinter
aber die letzten paar Meter
Kabel sind heute bei ganz vielen
Leuten mit einem Festnetztelefon
ganz normale
Oldschool 1900er
Telefontechnik
analoge, analoges
2A Kabel, also nicht
alle Kabel sind analog
2A dann Kabel, analoge Telefon
Zeug drüber, wer hat heute noch
ein Festnetztelefon, ich hab noch ein Festnetztelefon
ich benutze das zwar nicht, aber
ich hab noch eins
ich hab noch, ich hab ein Fritz Phone
sogar zwei, eins im ersten Stock
und eins im Erdgeschoss stehen
aber ich benutze das so gut wie nie
meine Mutter benutzt das aber
die telefoniert irgendwie nur mit dem Festnet, keine Ahnung
ob, obwohl ich der
obwohl ich der vor
paar Jahren ein
iPhone SE geschenkt hab
und jetzt mittlerweile hat sie sogar
einen iPhone
10 glaube ich
also insofern, ja aber
das ist halt, das ist halt noch mehr Boomer
ja, die
weiß ich
die bringt das nicht im Kopf zusammen
dass sie genauso gut mit dem Handy telefonieren könnte
als mit dem Festnetz
so, gucken wir mal weiter, aber damals dachte ich so
Telefone ist der moderne
krasse Scheiß, ja
damals hast du dich auch übelst gefeiert
da hat sie dann so Spezialfunktionen
auf dem Telefon
wie zum Beispiel
T-Net Box
einschalten und so
kennt das noch
jemand? T-Net
T-Net Box?
das war der Anrufbeantworter von der Telekom
das ist quasi in der Cloud
gehostet, der damals schon in der
Cloud gehostete
Anrufbeantworter von der Telekom
ich hab heute gar keinen
Anrufbeantworter mehr, Anrufbeantworter ist total out
die Leute sollen mich auf dem Handy anrufen
entweder gehe ich dran oder nicht, fertig aus
Schnellwahltasten
und sowas, ja
ich muss es euch jetzt nochmal zeigen
wahrscheinlich ist es Recycled Story
ich habe es euch bestimmt schon mal gezeigt
und ich habe das, ich habe dieses Ding auch noch
irgendwo, ich habe das nämlich mitgenommen
beim Umzug, weil das ist so ein Ding
das behalte ich, bis ich irgendwann mal den Löffel abgebe
weil ich das Gerät so nice finde
und zwar, ich hatte damals
als Modem
Elsa Micro Link Office
und dieses Teil
Alter, dieses Teil
da geht mir heute noch einer drauf ab
weil das so
eines meiner ersten
Technikgeräte war
wo ich so richtig begeistert von war
was das alles kann
so, also
das war ein 56k Modem
allerdings, nicht einfach nur
ein 56k Modem
man sieht es ja hier teilweise
nein, das war, jetzt haltet euch fest
das war einmal ein 56k Modem
ich glaube hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es
ja, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut auf dem Bild
exzellent, guck mal
das war nicht nur ein 56k Modem
das hatte
das hatte integrierten
Anrufbeantworter und
und, Leute
und, Fax
und nicht etwa einfach nur, dass du damit
Fax verschicken konntest, nein
das hatte integrierten Speicher
da konntest du Telefonanrufe
aufnehmen drauf
und Faxe empfangen drauf
ohne das du ein Faxgerät
brauchtest, du hattest quasi
ein Gerät, was immer an war
Faxe empfangen konnte
und du konntest dir dann die Faxe auf dem Computer angucken
und auch auf dem Computer Faxe schicken
ohne das du ein Faxgerät brauchtest
das war richtig geil damals
weil Faxgeräte sind
da so richtig dumm und stehen in der Gegend rum
und Faxen drucken es dann aus
und sowas richtig dämlich
und damals schon
mit Speicher intern
ja Fritzbox kann, Leute
damals gab es noch keine Fritzbox
dazu konntest du damit auch am Rechner telefonieren
ja
Rechner telefonieren, guck mal
du konntest, siehst du ja auch hier
direkt anschließen
Mikrofon und sowas, du konntest damit telefonieren
du konntest am Rechner telefonieren
du konntest damit Faxe verschicken, Faxe empfangen
Anrufe aufzeichnen
als Anrufbeantworter
und als Modem benutzen
Telefonanschluss und so auch
das war damals richtig nice
das sind Knöpfe
das sind keine Stecker, das sind Knöpfe
du konntest hier zum Beispiel
vorspulen, zurückspulen auf dem Anrufbeantworter
du konntest nächste
Nachricht anhalten, nächste Nachricht
Fax an- und
ausschalten, Nachricht löschen
du konntest Anrufbeantworter Ansage aufnehmen
oder
du hast hier drauf gedrückt
und dann hat es dir gesagt, sie haben
5 Nachrichten und sowas
das hat dann auch vorne dementsprechend
dementsprechend geplinkt
wenn du Faxe hattest
es ist mir
immer suspekt, wenn Internetseiten nicht richtig
Mime Types haben
ja, guck du hattest hier vorne auch einen
Plinker für Voice Nachrichten sind
da oder Faxe sind eingegangen
und da ging mir immer richtig drauf ab
das hat grün geplinkt so schnell
immer richtig drauf ab, wenn dann Voice
Nachrichten geplinkt haben
also
das da
da bin ich richtig drauf abgegangen damals
das war auch ziemlich teuer für die damalige Zeit
ich glaube das hat 150 Mark
oder so gekostet, ich weiß jetzt höre ich mich an
wie der übelste Opa
aber das war halt 1997
so in dem Dreh
richtiges Poggers Teil
ach ja Chat
wie hat man das eigentlich an Computer
angeschlossen
ein und ausschalten
angeschlossen hast du eine serielle
Schnittstelle an Computer
ach und jetzt haltet euch mal
fest, ratet mal
ohne nachzugucken, ratet mal
wie viel internen Flash
Speicher dieses Modem hatte
wie viel internen Speicher
hat es gehabt
wohlgemerkt für Sprachnachrichten
und für Faxe
1 MB
ich glaube es hatte
4 MB
bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ob das hier steht
4 MB hatte das
Chipforum 2002
ich bin mir relativ sicher
dass es 4 MB Flash Speicher hatte
aber muss man sich mal überlegen
mit 4 MB konnte man damals
einige Sprachanrufe schon aufnehmen
die Qualität könnt ihr euch dementsprechend vorstellen
die Qualität der Sprachanrufe war jetzt nicht so
geil, aber man hat alles verstanden
ja
das ist schon pock
das habe ich immer noch irgendwo
das werde ich nie wegschmeißen
das war so eines meiner Lieblingsgeräte
Leute
habe ich es ernsthaft geschafft
1 Minute 12 Video zu gucken
und dazu jetzt eine halbe Stunde zu reden
oder wie
Standard
ok jetzt gucken wir uns das aber fertig an
warum es nie jemand wirklich benutzen wollte
bis es heute zum Standard in der täglichen Kommunikation wurde
bleibt dran
liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet Surfer
herzlich willkommen hier bei
du du du
also die Erfindung des Telefons
hat damals ein bisschen was verändert
surprise, aber nur kurze Zeit
nachdem sich Alexander G. Bell
1876 das Telefonpatent
gesichert hat, kamen erst Ideen
zum Videotelefon auf
ganz wichtig dabei, es gab damals ja auch noch keinen Fernseher
das heißt die ganzen Gedanken rund um Videotelefonie
sind Hand in Hand
mit Gedanken rund um das Medium Fernsehen
gegangen, also sowas wie Live Übertragung
von Sportveranstaltungen oder Nachrichten
heute voll normal, damals der neue
richtig heiße Scheiß
und wahrscheinlich hat das die Menschen damals ähnlich fasziniert
wie uns heute generative
KI Modelle, ja und genau deswegen wurde da auch
intensiv dran gearbeitet und zwar
zeitgleich in den USA, in Deutschland
und auch in Frankreich, gab viele Ideen
wie das Medium Videotelefonie
die Kommunikation verändern könnte
zum Beispiel hier, das ist eine Karikatur
aus dem Jahr 1879 und
ja das trifft schon ziemlich gut wie Videotelefonie
vor einem großen Bildschirm heute aussieht
ja ok, die Mikrofone sind anders
als die Lautsprecher, aber sonst sieht das
wahrscheinlich waren die Mikrofone und
Lautsprecher besser als das was die Leute
heute haben, sah heute doch genauso aus, wenn ich
im Wohnzimmer vom Fernseher Videotelefonie
mache, ja und auch diese Illustration
aus dem Jahr 1910
ja das ist halt schon ein bisschen
antik, ja
aber guck mal mit Beamer
das macht bestimmt der ein oder andere mit Beamer
ja, kann man mal machen
und auch im Kino wurden
guck mal, wie
das Gechill da da sitzt
aus dem Jahr 1910
ja, kann man mal machen
und auch im Kino wurden natürlich
Videotelefonate gezeigt, einmal hier
1925 im US amerikanischen
Film Up the Ladder und in
Deutschland zwei Jahre später im Film
Metropolis wird eine Industriestadt
aus dem Jahr
2026 gezeigt und hier benutzt der
Meister ein Videotelefon
2026?
Das ist ja in drei Jahren
Vorarbeiter zu sprechen, insgesamt
ja das ist halt blöd bei den ganzen Science Fiction
Filmen von früher, da haben die auch gedacht
dass wir 2000 schon fliegende Autos haben
und sowas
hat das Thema in den 1920er Jahren an Fahrt
aufgenommen, einmal hier in den USA
da seht ihr wie 1927 das erste
Telefonat mit Video stattgefunden
hat, zwischen dem damaligen US
Wirtschaftsminister Herbert Hoover
und dem AT&T Chef, also wenn man das
überhaupt Videotelefonie nennen möchte, denn
das Video war mehr so ein Begleitbild
und vor allem auch einseitig, also
es konnten sich nicht beide gleichzeitig sehen
also mehr so ein Tech Showcase, der der
anwesenden Journalistengemeinde zeigen sollte
wie weit man schon bei der Entwicklung war
das Videosignal wurde über eine
extra Leitung gesendet und war mit 18
Bildern pro Sekunde auch nicht wirklich flüssig
naja
da habe ich schon schlechteres gesehen
auch heute, zumindest nach heutigen Standards
heute haben filmische Bewegungen
mindestens 24 Bilder, also aber 18
FPS für ein Webcam Video
da habe ich schon mehr Geruckel
gesehen, richtig los mit der
Videotelefonie ging es aber tatsächlich
in Deutschland, hier wurde 1929
auf der sechsten großen deutschen
Funkausstellung in Berlin, dem
IFA Vorgänger, ein Prototyp einer
Videotelefonanlage gezeigt
aber auch wenn sich die Leute damals in zwei Kabinen
die wenige Meter voneinander entfernt waren
gesehen und gehört haben, es gibt
heute leider keine Bilder mehr davon
nur Texte, dem Entwickler
Gustav Krawinkel ging es damals vor allem
darum, den Menschen zu zeigen, dass
Telefonie einen wichtigen visuellen Teil
der menschlichen Kommunikation außen
voll ist, das Problem war damals aber, dass
die Technik mit dem mechanischen
Lochabtaster, also der Kamera, nicht mit
den höherzeiligen Fernsehnormen kompatibel
war, weil der Abtaststrahl deutlich
heller gestellt werden müsste und damit
die Nutzer und Nutzerinnen zu sehr geblendet
hätte und dadurch das relativ dunkle
Glimmlampenbild gar nicht mehr sichtbar
gewesen wäre und deswegen wurde diese
Technik dann erstmal auf Eis gelegt
aber ihr wisst 1933
begann dann ein sehr dunkles Kapitel
der deutschen Geschichte und für die Nazis
war das Fernsehen und die...
Die hatten andere Sachen favorisiert
was Technologie angeht
nicht so sehr Videoübertragung
Videotelefonie aus Propagandazwecken
so interessant, um der Welt die vermeintlich
technologische Stärke zu präsentieren
dass die Forschung daran intensiviert
wurde, ja und dann gab es...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich umgedreht
erwartet, ich hätte gedacht, da ist jetzt erstmal gar nichts
passiert bis nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg
weil die halt eben andere Prioritäten hatten
1936 mit der Fernsehsprechstelle
tatsächlich das weltweit erste
kommerzielle Videotelefonsystem
auf der Leipziger Frühjahrsmesse
konnte die Öffentlichkeit den Vorläufer
von unseren heutigen Videokonferenzsystemen
sehen, dort wurde auch
der erste Anruf zwischen Leipzig
und Berlin gemacht und natürlich für
Propagandazwecke missbraucht
zum kurz danach war das System für alle
die bereit waren dafür zu bezahlen
zugänglich, nicht zu Hause, sondern in
ausgewählten Reichspostämtern
in Leipzig, Berlin, später auch Nürnberg
München und Hamburg, dort gab es extra
Räume, die mit einem Bildschirm und einem
Telefon ausgestattet wurden
So eine Frisur hatte meine Oma
auch als sie jung war
technisch hat das
das ganze im wesentlichen über die damalige
Fernsehtechnik funktioniert, ein Jahr davor
1935 ging in Deutschland der
Fernsehprogrammbetrieb über
Breitbandkabel an den Start, die Technik wurde
unter anderem für die Übertragung der Olympischen
Spiele 1936 in Berlin
eingesetzt, die Fernsehsprechstelle machte
Übertragungen mit 180 Zeilen
bei 25 Bildwechseln pro Sekunde
möglich, der Bildschirm dieser
Fernsehsprechstelle hatte damals die Maße von
20 x 20 cm
von der Qualität
20 x 20
das geht doch
irgendwie sogar
Peter hat das dann so ausgesehen
zum Vergleich, dieses Video hat 4K Auflösung
also 2160 Bildzeilen
das sind also 12 mal
Naja, man darf nicht vergessen, dass hier
das hier
muss ja auch auf einem Bildschirm
dargestellt werden, der
oh ja
ungefähr so ist
na gut, das passt jetzt
nicht bei euch überein
und dann sieht das doch wiederum
relativ brauchbar aus
ist doch vollkommen okay
Qualität her hat das dann so ausgesehen
zum Vergleich, dieses Video hat
4K Auflösung also 2160
und wir gucken es nur in
1080p
das sind also 12 mal
so viel wie bei der Fernsehsprechstelle
heißt selbst im Vergleich zu einem normalen
heute relativ kleinen 32 Zoll Fernseher
waren die Bildschirme in der
Fernsehsprechstelle quasi winzig
neben der Bildübertragung brauchte man auch
noch eine extra Telefonleitung, so dass
beide Gesprächspartner sich gesehen und gehört haben
das hat dann für ein 3 Minuten Gespräch
3 Reichsmark plus 50 Pfennig
Gebühr gekostet, doppelt so viel wie
ein normales Telefonat damals
laut dem Statistischen Bundesamt würde das
im Jahr 2022 einer
Kaufkraft von fast 17 Euro
entsprechen und ich sag mal so, wenn man den
technischen Aufwand dahinter sieht, war das eigentlich
günstig, aber natürlich trotzdem
sehr viel Geld und damit blieb der Erfolg
aus, in Hamburg zum Beispiel sollen nur
20 Verbindungen über die Fernsprechstelle
erfolgt sein, in Nürnberg rund
10 Verbindungen pro Monat
problematisch war neben den hohen Gebühren vor allem
auch die Tatsache, dass man ja nicht einfach jemanden anrufen
konnte, sondern sich irgendwie dafür
verabreden musste und erstmal eine Person
finden musste, die in der anderen Stadt gerade
ich mein
bisschen ältere unter euch werden das noch kennen
früher wenn man in den Urlaub gefahren ist
ist man dort auch erstmal an den
Telefon und hat bei Oma und Opa
angerufen und hat gesagt, man ist gut angekommen
also wenn man im Hotel war, ist man erstmal raus
hat irgendeinen Telefon gesucht
hat mal Münzen reingeschmissen
hat dann daheim angerufen
und hat gesagt, ja alles gut gelaufen, wir sind jetzt da
das ist nicht so nach dem
Motto mit, lasst uns mal
kurz am Flughafen noch eine SIM-Karte fürs Handy
holen und let's go
Zeit hat, deshalb sollen viele
Gespräche zum Ausprobieren auch mit
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern der Postämter
geführt worden sein. 1904
wurde der Dienst dann eingestellt
unter anderem auch um die bestehenden
Verbindungen exklusiv militärisch
nutzen zu können und dann war ja erstmal
Krieg und damit auch die Weiterentwicklung
des Videotelefons hinten angestellt
zwar hat der US-amerikanische
Kommunikationsanbieter AT&T auch
in den 30er Jahren an Videotelefonie
geforscht, übrigens genauso wie Frankreich
aber wie in Deutschland auch wurde diese
Forschung wegen des zweiten Weltkriegs nicht
fortgeführt. Nach dem Krieg lag
der Fokus vor allem in der Entwicklung des
Fernsehens als Unterhaltungsmedien
Da gab es dann
Videotext
für Interaktivität
das kennen ja wahrscheinlich
auch einige Leute nicht mehr
Moment, dafür gibt es noch eine Webseite
Moment, es gibt den Videotext als Webseite
Unwetterwarnung
Videotext
Informationen, ob und wie
in der Nachkriegszeit an der Videotelefonie
gearbeitet wurde, gibt es tatsächlich nicht
und so ging die Technikgeschichtsschreibung
erst Mitte der 50er Jahre
mit der Videotelefonie. Die bisherigen
Entwicklungen der deutschen Fernsehsprechstellen
sind aber in Vergessenheit geraten und
wurde auch von den Alliierten nicht mitgenommen
und inzwischen waren in weiten Teilen
der USA und Europa schon
Telefonleitungen zwischen Unternehmen und
Privathaushalten verlegt, deswegen musste man sich
irgendwie überlegen, wie man Videotelefonie
mit Telefonleitungen umsetzen kann
oder gut argumentieren, warum man in neue
Leitungen investieren sollte. Wenn euch das
im Detail interessiert, dann hier eine kleine Buchempfehlung
dazu, Face to Interface
Da wird ziemlich genau erklärt, wie das Videotelefon
langsam marktreif wurde
Haben wir schon die Frage, ob du auf
der Gamescom warst oder gehst?
Na gehen kann ich ja nicht mehr, die ist ja jetzt vorbei
oder ist die heute noch?
Ne, war ich nicht
Ich war auch schon die letzten paar Jahre nicht mehr
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr
Also Gamescom ist cool
wenn man
eben ein paar Leute online kennt
und die man wieder vor Ort sehen will, das fand ich persönlich
auch immer am besten an der Gamescom, tatsächlich
ab und zu mal ein paar Leute sehen, die man
nur online kannte
Aber zum Spiele angucken ist die Gamescom
eh schon unbrauchbar seit Jahren
Ich war sogar mal in Leipzig
Das ist schon richtig lange her, als es noch
Gamesconvention hieß, ja da war ich tatsächlich mal
Das ist schon so lange her
Ich weiß
Ich kann euch sogar sagen, welches Jahr das war
Das war das
Jahr, wo
Dark Messiah of
Might and Magic vorging
Übrigens ein sehr cooles Game, was wir auch irgendwann mal
glaube ich auch im Stream gespielt haben
Vorgestellt wurde
Das ist von, guck mal, das ist von 2006
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen
Das war 2006 dann wahrscheinlich
wo ich in Leipzig war
Schon richtig lange her
Da war der Frasier mit dabei
Und weil das jetzt wirklich so viele
Telefonen langsam
marktreif wurde, Link dazu
ist in der Beschreibung
Und weil das jetzt wirklich so viele Geräte und Entwicklungen sind
Hier mal der Schnelldurchlauf
der Highlights
des Telefons hat wie gesagt Mitte der 50er Jahre
wieder Fahrt aufgenommen und dann gab es wieder einige Prototypen
Zum Beispiel hat AT&T
1956 hier ein Gerät gezeigt
Das Bild hat
Ich könnte mir
original vorstellen, was meine Oma
zu diesem Bild jetzt gesagt hätte
Wo ich irgendwie gerade dran denke, wahrscheinlich
weil ich vorhin gesagt habe, die eine hatte eine Frisur
wie meine Oma. Wenn meine Oma
das Bild gesehen hätte
Dann hätte die gesagt
Ich kann es mir direkt mit ihren
Worten vorstellen
Die hätte sich das angeguckt
und hätte gesagt, aha, das ist der Griff zum Wegschmeißen
Das war so ein typischer Spruch
von meiner Oma
Und das ist der Griff zum Fortschmeißen
Das hätte einfach
original gepasst
über die normale Telefonleitung
versenden konnte
Oder hier ein Jahr später auf der Frankfurter Messe
ein Prototyp, der über die damalige Fernsehtechnik
funktionierte und dadurch deutlich mehr Kabel
und vier Bildschirme benötigte
Und im Prinzip haben sich bei den Herstellern
in den nächsten Jahren die Modelle durchgesetzt
die über Telefonleitung funktionieren
AT&T hat es ab 1964
mit dem Picture Phone auf dem Markt
probiert. Die Geräte standen zu Beginn
an öffentlich zugänglichen Orten, waren aber
relativ teuer. Telefon mit Wählscheibe
Tatsächlich hatte meine Oma auch
extrem lang Telefon mit
Wählscheibe
ein orangenes
ein orangenes Telefon mit Wählscheibe hatte
die, ja sah
sah sehr sehr ähnlich
zu dem aus
ein orangenes Telefon mit Wählscheibe
hatte meine Oma
das war wahrscheinlich
auch das Modell
das sieht dem sehr ähnlich
und
ähm
die
das war ja damals Impulswahl
ich glaube viele Omas hatten das
daher kommt das ja
du hast das hier ja aufgezogen
und das hat dann unterschiedlich viele Impulse abgesetzt
ich zähl das jetzt mal
weil wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute
sowas nicht mal mehr angefasst haben
heute, ja
du hast das hier aufgezogen
dann hast du es losgelassen
und beim loslassen hat es dann gemacht
und diese Impulse
entsprachen halt einer Nummer
deswegen konntest du ja auch
deswegen
deswegen durftest du den auch nicht
schneller zurückdrehen als es erlaubt hat
also du konntest da übelst dran drücken
und dass es schneller zurückdrehen
aber dann hast du es kaputt gemacht
deswegen gab es damals auch Leute
die konnten mit dem Hebel wählen
und nicht mit der Scheibe
versteht ihr was ich meine?
also dieses Telefon wird ja hier oben
aus so zwei Plastikdingern aufgelegt
und
die Plastikdinger waren ja eigentlich dafür da
quasi das
zu signalisieren das aufgelegt ist
im Endeffekt, ja
aber du konntest auch den Hörer abheben
und dann oben an diesen
Plastikdingern, wo du eigentlich den Hörer drauf
legst, konntest du selbst Impulse
wählen, also es gab Leute
die konnten mit dem Impuls
die konnten Impulswahl machen
die konnten wählen ohne Wählscheibe
indem sie nur oben den Hebel gedrückt haben
weil es hat ja auch Impulse gegeben
richtige Hackermans
war auch nicht wirklich schneller
ohne Hörer
ja, leider haben die
die steht überall der Hörer drauf
ähm
leider nicht
hier
hier sieht mans, guck
hier oben hast du Kontakte
wo der Hörer drauf gelegt wurde
und auf die Kontakte konntest du selbst
Telefongabel
ja sowas ist es
Gabel
ja genau
hier
und auf diese Dinger konntest du
von Hand klicken
und das hat dann gewählt
weil das auch Impulse gegeben hat
also konntest anstatt beispielsweise
fünf zu wählen, konntest du auch
auf dem
auf der Gabel oben drauf hauen
ja
aber da muss ich sagen
ich hab das noch mitbekommen, aber das war auch
das war auch
noch irgendwie so ein bisschen vor meiner
Technikzeit, ja
und das war damals auch schon komplett
outdated, aber mein Oma und Opa hatten
sowas halt noch
das führte dazu, dass sich die erste
Generation der Picturephones einfach
nicht durchsetzen konnte
1970 gab es drei bezahlte Anrufe
1970 kein einziges
in Frankreich kamen die Videotelefone
wie hier das Visio-Phone von Matra
sogar nie über die ersten Marktversuche
und eine Konzeptphase hinaus
die waren halt auch sehr klobig
und wahrscheinlich teuer as fuck
und die Gegenstelle hatte dann keins
und das scheiterte auch an der
Verbreitung höchstwahrscheinlich
kamen beispielsweise Modelle von Toshiba
die Telefone kannst du nicht anschließen
an der Fritzbox
die haben noch keinen RJ11
oder was das ist, Stecker
kann man vielleicht umbauen oder so
die haben noch einen anderen Stecker gehabt
die hat noch keinen RJ11, die Telefone
und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die Fritzbox
überhaupt noch Impulswahl kann
kann die Fritzbox
noch Impulswahl
ja die können das noch
und eine Konzeptphase hinaus
aus Japan kamen beispielsweise Modelle von Toshiba
oder Mitsubishi
guckte mal, die Japaner
das sieht gleich schon, guck mal
das sieht gleich schon deutlich
stylischer und praktischer aus
was die Japaner gebaut haben, oder?
im Vergleich zu dieser klobischen Kiste von vorhin
das sieht sogar recht stylisch aus
sieht ein bisschen aus wie zwei
Rückspiegel, die man zusammengeklebt hat, gell?
linker Rückspiegel, rechter Rückspiegel
zack zusammen und dann ein Fernseher
und eine Wählscheibe reingemacht
Modelle von Toshiba oder Mitsubishi
auf den Markt und Sony hat in den späten 80ern
mit dem PCT-15
ein eigentlich ziemlich futuristisches Gerät
auf den Markt gebracht, das konnte man sogar
anschließen und war so nicht auf den kleinen
integrierten Bildschirm angewiesen
wie auch bei den AT&T-Geräten war die Bildqualität
einfach zu schlecht und hat sich
deshalb nie durchgesetzt
laut einer AT&T-Befragung hatten die Leute wohl auch
einfach schlecht und hat sich
ich mein, da war ja die Bildqualität von diesem Nazi
Versuch besser
da war der Bildschirm
größer und höher aufgelöst
dafür hast du noch eine eigene
Telefonkabine dafür gebraucht
hier konntest du es daheim haben
laut einer AT&T-Befragung
hatten die Leute wohl auch einfach keinen Bock
dass sie zuhause gesehen werden konnten
und dann ist da natürlich auch noch das Henna-Ei-Problem
in der Videotelefonie, also die kritische Masse
die man erreichen muss, damit das überhaupt Sinn ergibt
hab ich ja eben auch schon gesagt
das ist ja klar, wenn du es kaufst
damals war das wahrscheinlich anteilmäßig
auch noch extrem teuer
und dann hatte die Gegenstelle keins
und die Gegenstelle hat sich keins gekauft, weil der Rest nix hatte
das ist immer so ein bisschen problematisch
ergibt halt auch keinen Sinn, wenn du der einzige bist, der so ein System hat
und wenn niemand in deinem Umfeld
so ein Ding hat, warum solltest du dir dann eins holen?
einen weiteren Versuch gab es dann in den 80er Jahren
mit der studiobasierten Videotelefonie
das waren extra Videokonferenzräume
die man sich mieten konnte
wir haben einen Preis gesehen, das waren zum Beispiel
2300 US-Dollar die Stunde
ja, und einige Unternehmen wie IBM
oder Boeing hatten sogar so eigene Räume
dafür, mit dem Ziel
die Anzahl an Dienstreisen zu verringern
und auch in Deutschland gab es solche Studioräume
wie zum Beispiel hier in Hannover
oder hier in Großbritannien, da haben sich Unternehmen
wie Shell extra Studios baut
um sich mit anderen Niederlassungen
zu verbinden
ja, aber auch das scheiterte
genauso wie der Versuch in Europa
an einem flächendeckenden Videotelefondienst zu arbeiten
im Zuge dessen gab es in Deutschland 1981
sogar schon fertige Pläne
innerhalb von 30 Jahren ganz Westdeutschland
mit Glasfaser zu versorgen
ja, und dann gab es einen Wechsel im Kanzleramt
und Helmut Kohl wollte lieber Kabelfernsehen
in einem Paralleluniversum
hat Deutschland heute das beste Glasfasernetz der Welt
in den 90er Jahren
hat man dann wieder an den endgültigen
Versuch der Videotelefone geglaubt
AT&T hat mit dem Videofone 2500
ein Gerät auf den Markt gebracht
das Farbbilder
was macht die da mit dem Kabel?
über die normale Telefonleitung übertragen konnte
möglich machte das
das aber auch, Leute
das Nazitelefon hatte 18 FPS
guckt euch mal das hier an
das Farbbilder über die normale Telefonleitung übertragen konnte
möglich machte das
das sind 0,5 FPS
also und da
da lagen jetzt was?
30 Jahre Entwicklungszeit
dazwischen
krass, oder?
also so mies war das ja
nicht
was sie damals zusammengebaut haben
Chat
ne, es war 1933
60 Jahre dazwischen
wie komme ich jetzt auf 30?
18 FPS
gut, damals hast du eine eigene Telefonkabine gebraucht
ein extra Chip zur Videokomprimierung
der hat allerdings die Qualität so bescheiden
dass auch dieses Produkt nicht den gewünschten Erfolg hatte
und auch in anderen Ländern
wie hier in Deutschland
gab es vergleichbare Geräte
hier zum Beispiel das Tview 100
es reicht für Mainstream Verbreitung halt nicht
wenn du nur so die richtig Hardcore Technik
Affinen Leute begeisterst
das kann am Anfang so ein bisschen für so
Early Adopter Kram
ganz gut sein, aber
damit setzt es halt nicht durch
Telekom
diese Geräte haben wie normale Telefone mit Bildschirm ausgesehen
im Prinzip wurde auf dem bestehenden Siemens Telefon
ein TFT Display
eine Kamera und einen Prozessor angeflanscht
und mit diesem Produkt hat die Telekom
eine große Werbekampagne gestartet
die einen fast vergessen lassen konnte
dass die Videotelefon, die damals in Deutschland
schon über 60 Jahre alt war
damit schrumpfen Entfernungen noch einmal um ein ganzes Stück
alles mit ISDN
alles über ein Netz
und ihr habt es euch vielleicht schon gedacht
auch diese Produkte konnten sich kommerziell
nicht durchsetzen
und das Videophone Toothout
das Problem, dass es wieder unsinnig teuer war
war dann auch das letzte Videotelefoniegerät
von AT&T
nach 75 Jahren haben sich die Amerikaner
dann damals final eingestanden
dass die Leute vielleicht lieber nur telefonieren
und sich dabei nicht sehen wollen
aber vielleicht lag es auch nur an der Technik
denn der richtige Durchbruch kam erst mit dem Internet
und Voice over IP
da gab es dann zwar auch extra Geräte für
wie hier von A-Core aus dem Jahr 2005
aber auch wenn diese IP Bildtelefone
direkt an den Router oder das Modem angeschlossen werden
konnten, war die durchschnittliche DSL Geschwindigkeit
in Deutschland damals einfach zu gering
um flächendeckend gute Bildqualität
zu gewährleisten
man würde sagen, ist sie heute noch
waren diese Geräte zwar vereinzelt im geschäftlichen
Umfeld erfolgreich, konnten sich aber auch
nicht durchsetzen
was dann wirklich zum Durchbruch geführt hat
waren rein softwarebasierte Lösungen
denn als Skype 2005 eine Videotelefonfunktion
hinzufügte, war das auf einmal
für alle kostenlos möglich
die einen Computer, eine Webcam und einen Internetanschluss hatten
und das wurden mit den Jahren
irgendwann fast alle
und mit steigender Internetbandbreite stieg dann auch
die Qualität der Anrufe
ja und als Apple 5 Jahre später mit FaceTime
und dem ersten iPhone mit Front Facing Kamera
die Videotelefonie auch noch im gleichen
Stil mobil gemacht hat
war das tatsächlich für alle nutzbar
und das auch in guter Qualität
ihr guckt euch dieses Video auch sehr wahrscheinlich
auf einem Videotelefonie kompatiblen Gerät an
ja und als 2020
dann das mit Corona losging
waren wir glaube ich alle ganz froh
dass wir so Videotelefone haben
und dass das dann auch der finale Durchbruch
für die Videotelefonie als
Massenkommunikationsmethode war
sowohl im beruflichen Kontext als auch
privat sind die Zahlen da durch die Decke gegangen
ich erinnere mich noch daran, dass ich
am Anfang der Corona-Zeit auf so Partys
auf Zoom übertragen worden bin
und da saß man dann so
alle so einzeln
vor ihren Bildschirmen ihre Limonade
getrunken, also es war interessant
das ist cringe
so nach dem Motto
wir sind jetzt zwar remote, tun aber so
als wären wir alle zusammen
da habe ich mich nach Möglichkeiten immer nicht
dran beteiligt an solchen Dingern
letztendlich nicht so durchgesetzt
aber im beruflichen Kontext auf jeden Fall
ja und jetzt hat sich ja auch die gesundheitliche
Lage einigermaßen normalisiert
und jetzt kann man nur spekulieren
gehen die Zahlen jetzt wieder runter
ich würde sagen ca. 50%
schaut gerade am Smartphone
beruflich ein wichtiges Kommunikationsmittel
und entwickelt sich das irgendwie mit VR
eine remote Weihnachtsfeier
das kann ich mir wirklich cringig vorstellen
schauen wir mal was wird
ich meine so ein kurzes hoch
an Videotelefonie im beruflichen Umfeld
gab es ja auch schon mal nach dem 11. September
weil Führungskräfte ungern fliegen wollen
das hat dann aber auch schnell wieder nachgelassen
wie ist das bei euch
benutzt ihr regelmäßig Videotelefonie
nervt euch das eher oder feiert ihr das
also ich sag euch ganz ehrlich
ich hab bei Teams meistens defaultmäßig die Kamera aus
das einzige
wo ich standardmäßig die Kamera immer anmache
ist unser 15 Minuten Daily
Geschwätze
ansonsten habe ich standardmäßig die Kamera aus
wozu brauche ich eine Kamera
wir wollen uns dann meistens irgendwas zusammen angucken
und die wollen mich nicht sehen
ich will die auch nicht sehen
und das passt
könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern wann ihr das das erste Mal gemacht habt
schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare
und natürlich
das erste Mal Videokonferenz
ich hab keine Ahnung
das wird aber schon ganz schön lange her gewesen sein
ich hab das sicherlich schon
zu
Skype
und ne
das erzähl ich euch nicht
ich kann mich daran erinnern
weil ich das erste Mal Internet Videokonferenz benutzt habe
ich sag nur
kennt noch einer
NetMeeting
das ist quasi so der
der Skype Vorgänger
ja
NetMeeting
das dürfte das erste sein
wo ich Videokonferenz
erlebt habe
gerne den Kanal abonnieren
konnte ICQ damals Video
am Anfang nicht
ICQ konnte noch nicht mal telefonieren
ICQ konnte Textnachrichten schreiben
und Sumo Volleyball
als Minispiel spielen
Sumo Volleyball
war eh das beste Game
ICQ
Du meinst was?
was meinst Du?
ICQ
ICQ hatte als Sound
Das hier
das ist das für ne befehlige Abstimmung
biscuit
welter Sinn von Abstimmung
Mit nur EIne im Feld
PC laptop Handy Tablet
warum hat sich ICQ nicht
ICQ hat sich durchgesetzt
ICQ war der mit Abstand
weitestverbreitesten Instant-Messenger
zur damaligen Zeit
ICQ
gehalten. Aber es war bei vielen Technologien, die kommen und gehen. Der Fall von ICQ ist immer
immer unbedeutender geworden. Irgendwann kam dann Skype und hat dem komplett den Rest gegeben. Ich
weiß, meine ICQ-Nummer heute habe immer noch, aber ich logg mich da nicht mehr ein. So, was können
wir uns jetzt als nächstes mal zu Gemüte führen hier? Was haben wir denn hier? Die zehn besten
Shooter aller Zeiten. Okay, Leute, das muss jetzt sein. Wenn Half-Life nicht vorne mit dabei ist,
taugt die Liste nicht. Also Half-Life 1 wohlgemerkt. Half-Life 2 darf auch drin sein, ist auch okay.
Aber Half-Life 1 muss. Also wenn du mich fragst, ist Half-Life 1 nicht nur der beste Shooter aller
Zeiten, gerade auch gemessen an der Zeit, wann er rausgekommen ist, sondern auch mit, naja, der
Einfluss, aber eines der mit einflussreichsten Shooter aller Zeiten.
Technisch kann es natürlich durchaus sagen, dass Doom und Quake und die Idsoft-Spiele da mehr
Einfluss hatten, weil, darf ich nicht vergessen, Half-Life 1 selbst basierte auf irgendeinem Quake 1
Engine-Fork. Aber, also, ich würde sagen, Half-Life war eines der einflussreichsten und ist für mich
eines, wenn nicht das, der beste Shooter ever. Okay, heute gibt es kein großes Vorgeplänkel,
denn hier läuft es.
Ihr wisst, wieso ihr hier seid. Ihr wollt unsere Top 10 der besten Shooter aller Zeiten sehen.
Und wir legen direkt los, aber zwei ganz wichtige Punkte muss ich noch loswerden. Es geht auch
super schnell, versprochen. Also erstens...
NordVPN kommt jetzt gleich oder sowas, hä?
Diese Top 10 hier sind Teil einer viel größeren Top 100 der besten Shooter aller Zeiten. Die komplette
Liste gibt's auf Gamestar.de. Schaut dort mal vorbei, da findet ihr dann auch Half-Life 2, bevor
jetzt gleich wer meckert. Und zweitens, diese Liste hier ist natürlich objektiv richtig. Wir
haben noch ein bisschen Zeit. Wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Und das mit wissenschaftlichen Kriterien eruiert.
Wisst ihr, es gibt immer noch einen Riesenanteil an Leuten, die verstehen das nicht, dass das
ein Witz ist. Die denken, der meint das ernst. Also, klar, im Internet tut man sich manchmal
schwer damit, wenn das eine gesagt wird und offensichtlich das andere gemeint ist. Aber
es gibt Leute, die haben da überhaupt kein Gespür für. Die denken jetzt, wie? Wie kann
der sagen, dass das 100% richtig ist?
Wenn ihr also nicht mit jedem Platz einverstanden seid, dann liegt ihr falsch. Denn nicht nur,
nichts an dieser Liste, absolut gar nichts, hat mit unserem persönlichen Geschmack oder
Subjektivität zu tun. Videospiele sind ja wie Zahnpasta immer objektiv messbar. Also,
wie es meckert wär. So, und jetzt geht's los.
Let's go.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von Genshin Impact. Erkundet ab dem 16. August.
Meint ihr, der war auch schon mal in einer Wüste?
16. August. Kraft, es gibt jetzt Impact und stellen Genshin Fanmei und Femina Trick auf die Helden im Release mit am 16. August.
Und stellen Genshin Fanmei und Femina Trick auf die Helden im Release mit am 16. August.
Ja, dass ich das mit den Primo Gems sage, da waren sie auch ganz scharf drauf.
Quake 3, äh, sorry, Quake 3 Arena.
Quake 3 ist auch...
Der hat die Top 10 auf jeden Fall verdient.
...24 Jahre nach Release in Deutschland noch indiziert.
Deshalb läuft hier im Hintergrund die Browser-Ante Quake...
By the way, Leute, nur mal so für den Fall der Fälle.
Falls jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt...
Sorry, Quake 3 Arena.
Quake 3 ist auch...
Falls jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt, guckt euch mal die Noobs an, die treffen sich gar nicht.
Das sind zwei der besten Quake-Spiele ever.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie irgendwelche Noob-Aufnahmen hier zeigen würden.
Ich glaube, Rafa spielt heute noch.
Ja, das ist Quake Live, das... egal.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, der spielt heute noch.
Und ich glaube, der hat letzten sogar irgendein Quake-Turnier sogar wieder gewonnen.
...24 Jahre nach Release in Deutschland noch indiziert.
Deshalb läuft hier im Hintergrund die Browser-Variante Quake Live.
Die 2010 rauskam und ich...
Okay, also lasst mich euch eine Geschichte erzählen, die absolut gar nichts mit Quake 3 zu tun hat.
Meine Kollegin Petra Schmitz hatte damals über 2000 Mark ausgegeben für einen Multiplayer-Shooter.
Neuer Rechner.
Nennen wir ihn natürlich nicht Quake 3, weil sie diesen besagten Shooter so ernst genommen hat,
dass sie ohne Internet-Flatrate damals ihr Telefon abrechnete.
Ja, sowas ähnliches habe ich auch geschafft, nur dass ich MMO gespielt habe.
Ohne Internet-Flatrate.
Da hatte ich auch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 500 Euro oder war das schon, glaube ich, 500 Euro oder so in Telefonrechnung.
...online spielen musste.
So gut war dieses Spiel.
Verständlich.
Dieser Petra-Shooter nahm genau wie sie seinen Multiplayer richtig ernst.
So ernst, dass Profis sogar die Effekte ausschalteten, um die Einzel-Frame-Raten hochzuschrauben.
Oder vielleicht ist er auch schon in Rente.
Die ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Keine Ahnung.
...Arena-Ballereien.
Prägte.
...unsterbliche Begriffe wie Instagip und zeigte der Welt da draußen,
Multiplayer-Shooter sind die Zukunft.
Übrigens zeigte...
Ja, und danach gab es nie wieder einen, der so erfolgreich und bekannt war wie Quake 3.
Ich meine, es gab noch Unreal Tournament und so, dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen,
weil ich will Unreal Tournament spielen.
Aber Quake 3 dürfte wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch das Größte und Bekannteste sein.
...dass 1999 auch ein anderer indizierter Multiplayer-Shooter namens...
Unreal?
...nicht Unreal Tournament.
Ja, Unreal Tournament.
...welchen auch immer ihr jetzt streng genommen besser oder schlechter findet,
diesen ersten Shootern verdanken wir all das, was danach kam.
Und was haben wir?
Viele Stunden in Multiplayer-Shootern wie definitiv nicht Quake 3 verbracht.
Hach.
Platz Nummer 9.
Doom 1.
Apropos verdanken.
Das Shooter-Genre verdankt Doom eine ganze Menge.
Das Deathmatch, grandioses Level-Design, umfangreiche Singleplayer-Kampagnen,
unterschiedliche Schwierigkeitsgrade.
Unvergessliche Monster-Designs.
Doom ist bis heute einfach Kult.
So sehr, dass es ja mittlerweile ein ganzes Subgenre gibt,
das Glanz und Glorie der 90er zurückbringen will.
Boomer-Shooter wie Warhammer 40k Boltgun machen...
Der hat echt Spaß gemacht, das Game.
Boltgun habe ich zweimal durchgespielt.
Schwer war leider nicht schwer genug.
Finde ich gut.
Fand ich ein gutes Game.
...aus ihren Vorgängern definitiv kein Geheimnis.
Und auch das erste Doom wird selbst 2023...
...von Fans noch gezockt.
Ja gut, es gibt ja auch 30 Milliarden Mods.
Ich glaube, Doom dürfte mit das meistgemordete Spiel aller Zeiten sein.
...Ballereien gegen höllische Horden, das Abklappern von Secrets
und generell der Charme dieses Shooters einfach genauso unsterblich sind
wie der Doom-Marine selbst.
Platz Nummer 8.
Max Payne 2.
Damit weg von den 90ern und hin zu einem meiner absoluten Lieblinge.
Ich persönlich mochte Max Payne 1 mehr.
Max Payne 2 ist heute eigentlich relevant.
Denn auf der einen Seite erleben wir nämlich ein wunderbares Action-Revival durch Pistolen-Pornos
wie John Wick 4 oder Tyler Rake Extraction.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Was für ein Ding?
Wer extracted wen?
...im Gaming nach wie vor absoluter Mangel an Spielen, die genau diese spezielle Stilrichtung
von Action spielbar machen.
Die gute alte John-Wu-Kugelhölle.
Raue Anti-Helden und Heldinnen, die in Büro...
Max, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ja.
...in Büro räumen, Spelunken in abgeranzten Hotels und Mafia-Clubs Blei regnen lassen,
die über Tische hechten, während links und rechts Kugeln in PC-Bildschirme Kartons und
Ramschkisten einschlagen, Papierstapel fliegen durch den Raum, der Putz rieselt von den Wänden.
Ach eben, John-Wu.
Und das natürlich noch garniert mit allerlei Bullet-Time-Stunts, die fast völlig aus dem
Gaming verschwunden sind.
Seit Max Payne 2 hat es kein Spiel geschafft, das meisterhafte dieser Schießereien würdig
vorzusetzen.
Nicht mal Max Payne 3, so gut es auch sein mag.
Kein Stranglehold, kein Wet und Gott bewahre, kein El Matador konnte es je wieder mit dem
Action-Hoch eines Max Payne 2 aufnehmen.
Und bevor ihr...
Okay, lass ich mir gefallen.
Max Payne 2 war ein richtig gutes Game, aber ich fand Max Payne 1 hat mich mehr abgeholt
damals.
...jetzt irgendwer Ö-Nostalgie-Brille johlt, Max Payne 2 ist auch aus heutiger Sicht noch
ein verdammt guter Shooter.
Ich finde, das ist ein Spiel, das kommt aus einer Zeit, das ist jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig
mies gealtert, das kann man sich noch angucken.
Max Payne 1 sieht dagegen doch ziemlich altbacken aus.
Vor allem das Beste ist...
Face.
Das ist ja der Drehbuchschreiber von denen, oder was heißt der Drehbuch, der Story-Script-Schreiber
von Remedy, den sie da einfach als Gesichtstextur benutzt haben.
Ideen stecken.
Dass jeder Kill die Bullet-Time weiter verlangsamt zum Beispiel.
Oder dass Feinde physikalisch auf jede einzelne Kugel reagieren.
Max Payne 2 erzählt außerdem eine fantastische Geschichte, jede Figur kann Freund oder Feind
sein, es bleibt bis zum Ende spannend.
Ich habe als Teenager Tage damit verbracht, jede einzelne Action-Szene des Spiels rauf
und runter zu spielen, mit Mods noch mehr Manöver zu aktivieren, den Matrix-Soundtrack
reinzupatchen, ich konnte die Dialoge irgendwann mitsprechen.
Max Payne 2 ist bis heute ein absolutes Meisterwerk und sollte viel mehr Shootern als Vorbilder.
Es geht Shooter, nicht Ego-Shooter.
Platz Nummer 7 Rainbow Six Siege
Da kann man sich jetzt sicherlich drüber streiten, aber okay, es ist ja seine Liste, darf er
auch reinbringen was er will.
Aber zumindest eine Sache hat Rainbow Six hingekriegt, die haben ein richtig gutes Comeback hingelegt,
nach dem ziemlich verkackten Start.
... und die Fans lieben es.
Da vergisst man schnell, wie bedeutend das Spiel ist.
Das Spiel ist wirklich toll.
Das ist das Spiel, das so stolz am Siege eigentlich ist.
Der Multiplayer-Shooter startete Ende 2015 als ne kaputte Baustelle.
Die Matches liefen nicht richtig rund, der Singleplayer war einfach nur lahm, gut ist
er bis heute noch, kaum wer wollte dem Spiel ne Zukunft garantieren.
Doch Ubisoft blieb an der Sache dran und das zahlte sich aus.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht esoterisch klingen, aber so sehr es uns manche Open Worlds auch
weismachen wollen, ein meisterhaftes Spiel kannst du nicht einfach nach ner Formel entwickeln.
Schaut euch die ganzen Battle-Royale-Klonen an, die auf dem Papier alles genauso wie Fortnite
und Warzone machen, aber es will einfach nicht Klick machen.
Ich mein...
Na gut, das Ding ist halt so, warum sollten die Leute irgendeinen 0815-Fortnite-Klon spielen,
wenn sie auch Fortnite spielen können, ne?
Und bei Fortnite merkst du halt auch, man kann jetzt von dem Game an sich, kann's mögen
oder nicht, aber da merkst du, dass da Leute dahinter sitzen, die wissen, wie man gescheite
Spiele macht.
Warzone bekommt ja nicht mal sich selbst vernünftig fortgesetzt.
Rainbow Six Siege erreichte durch Updates einen Punkt, an dem es für Millionen von
Menschen Klick machte.
Die zerstörbaren Wände, die unterschiedlichen Operatoren wie Sledge, IQ, Thermite und Co.,
die komplexen, aber lesbaren Maps...
Battle-Royale nicht als Arma-Mod gestartet?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, dieses ganze Zombie-Zeug und dementsprechend auch, sagen
wir mal so, Escape vom Tarkov und so die ganzen Vorgänge, das waren, das waren Arma, DayZ
und sowas, das waren Arma-Mods.
Aber ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kommt das auch daher, ja.
Six Siege bietet Teams unendliche Möglichkeiten, die Gegner durch immer neue Strategien auf
die Bretter zu schicken.
Dieser Shooter ist einfach magisch.
Und das alles in gnadenlos tödlichen Matches, wo eine einzige Salve den Untergang bringen
kann.
Jeder Fan erinnert sich an sein allererstes Ace, seinen allerersten Klatsch, an diese
zig Momente, wo es mit Ach und Krach noch irgendwie geklappt hat.
Ja, unter anderem.
Und dann all die Male, wo man durch die Deckel zephiert wurde.
Auch acht Jahre nach Release ist Rainbow Six Siege nach wie vor ein Meisterwerk und der
beste Beweis, dass die Multiplayer-Welt auch heute noch richtig gute Ideen und richtig
gute Ausführungen zu belohnen weiß.
So, Platz 6.
I just came to say Halo 2.
Als Halo 2 im November 2004 erschien, standen die Fans im Rahmen einer Launch-Party zwei
Häuser blocksweit Schlange auf dem New Yorker.
Times Square.
Szenen, die Gaming-Geschichte schrieb.
Bei solchen Sachen muss ich mich immer daran erinnern.
Hat jetzt mit Halo nichts zu tun.
Kennt ihr das Video, wo beim Mediamarkt die Scheibe zusammenbricht, weil die alle World
of Warcraft kaufen wollen?
Keine Ahnung, ob es davor noch ein Video gibt.
Mediamarkt.
Scheibe.
Mindener Tageblatt.
Computer-Spiel-Fans.
Alles klar.
Vor zwölf Jahren.
Aber da bricht nicht die Scheibe.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
bekommen sollte. Doch dieser Hype ist ein Grunpoops verglichen mit dem, was Halo 2 nach Release
auslösen würde, im Single wie im Multiplayer. Ich spiele die Kampagne alle zwei, drei Jahre
nochmal durch und kann euch auch 2023 attestieren, es gibt kaum eine bessere Shooter-Sandbox. Gerade
in der aufgehübschten Remaster-Variante der Master Chief Collection. Auf den ersten Blick
bin ich vielleicht bloß ein rüstiger Hühner mit Pumpgun und dicker Faust, also jetzt auch im Spiel
meine ich, der sich Raumstation für Raumstation durch Alien-Horden ballert, doch unter der
Oberfläche ist Halo 2 ein riesiges Getriebe aus kleinen Zahnrädern, die meisterhaft ineinander
greifen. Jedes Level von Halo 2 ist ein Erlebnis, selbst beim wiederholten Durchspielen. In einem
Anlauf fahre ich im Panzer durch New Bombaza, im nächsten wird mir das Ding unter dem Hintern
weggeschossen und ich muss plötzlich selbst überlegen, wie ich die feindlichen Banshee-Jäger
ohne Riesenrohr vom Himmel hole. Und der Multiplayer? Och, der Multiplayer.
Halo 2 hat modernes Matchmaking auf den Konsolen erfunden. Es war das Spiel,
für das Freundeskreise reihenweise Xbox-Konsolen zu irgendjemandem nach Hause gekarrt haben,
um eine mehrstöckige LAN-Party zu veranstalten. So wie wir PC-Kids über Counter-Strike und
definitiv nicht Quake 3 schwärmen, so jubeln Konsoleros über Halo. Es gibt wenige Shooter,
die so gut altern wie Halo 2. Jahrelang hat die Ko-
Leider haben sie es halt komplett verkackt, ne? Ich mein, 3 war auch noch riesengroß damals,
mit Lm-, äh, MLG.
Playlists und sowas, aber danach ging's abwärts.
Konkurrenz versucht, das Erfolgsrezept zu kopieren. Diverse vermeintliche Halo-Killer scheiterten
kolossal und bis heute verdankt die Halo-Marke ihre Komplimente ganz-
Wie ist Halo Infinite jetzt? Keine Ahnung, hat keine Spieler mehr. War eigentlich ganz gut.
Zu Release. Aber da kam halt nix nach. Naja. Naja! Hat ja weniger als Battlefield 2042.
Und was witzig ist, dass Battlefield 2042 erst
dies duo Ward 1 als Beispiel gebracht hat, warum ihr Spiel so schlecht gestartet ist.
Destiny 2 läuft recht eh, das sind ja auchバン . Die wissen ja auch if man solche
Games macht. Den Meisterwerken von einst! Halo mag heute lange
nicht mehr so wichtig sein wie damals, aber ohne ein Halo 2...sähe die Shooter-Landschaft
definitiv ganz anders aus.
Einfache Frage...diät rülpet々 Expresss Цена-Restaurantata?!
Ich stability gew Cayla curve?
Flatz. Nummer vier.
Fünf, Hunt Showdown.
Als Hunt Showdown zum ersten Mal angekündigt wurde ...
Ah, okay, da ist nicht meins.
... haben die Leute darüber gelacht.
Crytek stand damals nach mehreren eher maueren Projekten in keinen guten Ruf.
Das stimmt. Crytek hat ja auch mal einen MOBA gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, was je aus dem geworden ist,
aber ich glaube, das ist nicht mal released worden.
Dann kommen die mit einem Konzept, das ja überhaupt nicht funktionieren konnte.
Wilder Westen, aber ich laufe nur durch Sümpfe.
Bäh, Zombies ausgelutscht.
Und dann so ein merkwürdiger Mix aus PvP und Monsterbekämpfen.
Kein Fisch, kein Fleisch.
Wie konnte denn irgendwer das durchwinken?
Welcher Call-of-Duty-Fan verzichtet ...
Wie viele Spieler Battlefield 3 noch hat?
Schwer zu sagen, man sieht ja bloß die Steam-Zahlen.
Die Steam-Zahlen sind halt nicht gut, irgendwie 300 Leute oder so.
Du wirst abends vielleicht noch zwei Server-Rush vollbekommen.
Aber Steam, das Spiel kam auch erst zehn Jahre nach Release auf Steam.
Das ist nicht so wirklich repräsentativ.
Ähm, äh, Battlelog, gucken wir doch mal.
Du findest, du findest immer noch welche, ja, ja.
Ja, guck mal.
Also du kannst das definitiv noch spielen, wenn du willst.
Hast doch irgendwie so, na ja.
Sind wir mal kurz, du hast zehn Server, die noch voll sind.
Wer um irgendwelche altertümlichen Popelknarren aus dem US-Bürgerkrieg zu bedienen?
Tja, eine ganze Menge.
Und genau deshalb ist Hunt in dieser Serie.
Und zwar in dieser Liste, weil es der gesamten Branche gezeigt hat,
wie wichtig sich kreative Ideen und der Mumm und das Können, sie meisterhaft umzusetzen,
auch heutzutage noch führen kann,
obwohl das Shooter-Genre sich mit Battle Royale und Co. irgendwie festgefahren zu haben scheint.
Hunt Showdown ist in nahezu jeder Güteklasse ein Meisterwerk.
Ich meine, wie viele Multiplayer-Shooter verdienen alleine wegen ihres Soundtracks einen Award?
Wenn ich im Dickicht des Bayou von Lusiana herumschleiche,
entscheidet beileibe nicht nur mein Schussgeschick,
ob ich es hier lebend rauskriege.
Warte eine Minute, das war ein Hit?
...von Lusiana herumschleiche, entscheidet beileibe nicht nur mein Schussgeschick...
Was hittet der überhaupt?
Was zum...
Fuck!
Ist das da ein Spielerkopf oder was?
The fuck?
An der Hausecke?
Ja, aber der schießt nicht auf die Hausecke, der schießt irgendwo woanders hin.
Wenn hier einer steht, dann trifft er den aber auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ja, hier ist was.
Aber der schießt überhaupt nicht dahin.
Der schießt dahin.
Oder?
Kennt der Gegner rein, weil Bullet Travel Physics und so.
...mein Schussgeschick, ob ich es hier lebend rausschaffe.
Hunt ist manchmal mehr Stealth-Game als Shooter.
Ich muss genau hinhören, was meine Gegner machen,
mich clever positionieren, fallen stellen, antäuschen.
Und so entstehen Myriaden von Kombinationen,
die euch auf der einen Seite schon in den ersten Stunden Jubelerfolge verschaffen,
aber, naja, auch nach 23 Stunden habe ich immer noch das Gefühl,
bloß an der Oberfläche zu kratzen.
Hunt hat fantastisches Gunplay, das selbst Waffenexperten,
Feiern, es hat nützliche Tools und Fertigkeiten,
eine faszinierende Southern-Gothic-Atmosphäre,
bizarre Horrormomente und Kreaturen.
Nee, habe ich nie installiert, gespielt, sonst wie.
Das hat mich überhaupt nicht interessiert bis jetzt.
Und ein absolut meisterhaftes Sound-Design.
In keinem anderen Shooter kann dir schon ein knackender Ast
das Häufchen in die Hose treiben.
Jüngst erst wurde Regen ins Spiel gepatcht und nur in Hunt ist so was
ein großes Ding, weil der Regen auf jeder Oberfläche anders klingt.
Weil er die Matches komplett durchrütteln kann.
Mal zu meinen Gunsten, mal zu meinem Leid.
Und ich höre jetzt auf zu schwärmen.
Guckt einfach bei Fabian Sigismund vorbei,
wenn ihr verstehen wollt, warum dieses Spiel so unfassbar gut ist.
Ja, der geht da richtig drauf ab, schon seit Jahren.
Das hab ich mitgekriegt.
Auf gamestar.de vorbei, da hat mein Kollege Jesko
erst vor ein paar Tagen eine Kolumne über Regen geschrieben,
weil das in Hunt ein Thema ist.
So, machen wir weiter.
Platz Nummer vier, Counter-Strike.
Counter-Strike schlägt Wellen.
Verdient.
Damals schon Anfang der 2000er.
Myriaden von Jugendlichen stürzten sich in ...
Wir hatten bis jetzt wenig Half-Life.
... knallharte Multiplayer-Gefechte.
Es entstand eine halbe Subkultur aus Jokes, Soundbites und ...
Ohne Half-Life wär's mit Counter-Strike auch nicht.
... vergesslichen Deamspeak-Mitschnitten.
Dust, Dust 2 und andere Maps gingen in die Geschichte ein.
Counter-Strike war eine Startrampe für ernstzunehmenden E-Sport.
Es formierten sich erste Stars der Szene.
Kurzum, Counter-Strike ist einer der wichtigsten ...
Aber Office, na ja.
... Shooter aller Zeiten, bis heute.
Aber Counter-Strike geriet auch selbst.
Nicht unbedingt meine Lieblings-Map.
... Videospiel mal wieder vorwerfen wollte, die Jugend zu ruinieren.
Ja, das war damals ...
Counter-Strike war eine Zeit lang das Ding schlechthin,
wo Pfeiffer und Co. sich dran abreagiert haben.
Dass es die Jugend verroht und alle das Amok laufen.
... sollte das Ding sogar indiziert werden.
Die Gamestar sammelte damals 25.000 Unterschriften dagegen.
Und zum Glück blieb der Bannhammer aus.
Gern geschehen.
Diese Kontroversen haben dem Erfolg des Spiels aber keineswegs geschadet.
Aus der einstigen Half-Life-Mod wurde ein Multiplayer-Phänomen,
das selbst heute noch die Steam-Spieler-Charts anführt.
Und das völlig zu Recht,
denn Counter-Strike ist immer noch einer der besten Shooter überhaupt.
Und jetzt geht's langsam um die Wurst.
Platz Nummer drei, Battlefield 3.
Ah, ja.
Und bevor jetzt jemand ...
Da ... da geh ich mit.
... ein Feuerchen bekommt,
die anderen Battlefields kommen auch in unserer großen Top-100-Liste vor.
Aber wir hatten beim Auswählen die Qual der Wahl,
welches Battlefield die perfekte Symbiose
aus unseren wissenschaftlichen Kriterien wichtig
und auch heute noch geil am besten abbildet.
Und wenn ich mir die Kommentare unter jedem neuen Battlefield anschaue,
dann steht da immer, ach, ich will einfach nur ein neues Battlefield 3.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Wobei ich ... ich soll seit Anfang an schon sagen,
nein, ich will eigentlich kein Battlefield 3,
weil ich brauch kein Battlefield-3-Reskin.
Ich will ein gutes neues Battlefield,
was vielleicht das aufgreift, wo Battlefield 3 aufgehört hat.
Der Ruf der Sehnsucht kommt nicht von irgendwoher.
Battlefield 3 war damals in vielerlei Hinsicht Formvollendung
von all dem, was Battlefield so gut ...
Ich habe die blöde Vermutung, dass noch irgendein Call of Duty kommt.
Und das bleiben ja nur noch zwei und eins.
Und Half-Life muss ...
Also, wenn Half-Life nicht auf der Liste ist,
dann zweifel ich an der ganzen Liste.
Zerstörbare Umgebungen, riesige Maps,
eine beeindruckende Technik,
modernes Modern-Military-Szenario.
Ich konnte Jets fliegen, Panzer fahren ...
Aber wenn jetzt Battlefield 3 kommt, kommt bestimmt COD 4.
Ja, selbst die Singleplayer-Kampagne war gut.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Ein Battlefield mit einer guten Kampagne.
Ja, sackt Zement.
Da frag mal Alpha4Games,
wie gut er die Battlefield 3 Singleplayer-Kampagne findet.
Battlefield 3 hatte unvergessliche Maps
wie Operation Metro oder Caspian Border,
nach denen die Leute bis heute schreien.
Der Shooter spielt sich auch heute noch richtig gut.
Und ehrlicherweise sollte sich DICE
für alle Battlefields der Zukunft immer abschauen, was Teil 3 ...
Das Problem ist, dass die Leute alle abgehauen sind
und DICE sich irgendwie zu dumm anstellt.
Ich versteh's ja nicht.
Die bräuchten einfach Leute, die irgendwie begeistert sind,
begeisterte Shooter-Spieler sind,
und sich mal angucken, was Battlefield 3 gut gemacht hat.
Ich mein ...
Ich weiß nicht, was sie die letzten Jahre übertreiben.
... so beliebt gemacht hat.
Dann passiert auch nichts so Murks wie bei Battlefield 2042.
Ja, na ja.
Platz so zwei Uhr ...
Siehste?
War doch klar, dass so was jetzt noch kommt.
Okay, okay.
Muss man aber echt verhändeshalber sagen,
einflussmäßig war das auch ganz vorne mit dabei.
Da hat diese ganze No-Scope-Quick-Scope-Geschichte angefangen.
So richtig krass wurde es erst mit MW2.
Aber hier ging's los.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
heute, auch heute noch,
von der Kampagne her, vom Setting her und so,
ich fand COD 4 am besten.
Ich fand, das hatte noch einen ...
Das war schon so Arcade-Shooter-mäßig,
aber es hatte immer noch so ein bisschen so den ...
den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit, nenn ich's mal, drüber.
Der war ja dann spätestens bei MW2 komplett weg.
Black Ops 1 war nicht gedacht, irgendwie so was zu haben.
Aber ...
Black Ops 1 auch noch vielleicht ein bisschen.
Aber COD 4 hatte noch so den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit, so.
Das war danach halt komplett weg.
Oh.
Call of Duty 4.
Modern Warfare.
All Ghillied Up.
Shock and Awe.
Death From Above.
Wenn ihr die Missionsnamen eines Shooters
selbst 15 Jahre später noch auswendig runterbeten könnt,
dann ist das ein klares Indiz,
dass das Ding einiges richtig gemacht hat.
Und man muss sagen, in COD 4, das war zwar schon ...
Die Amis sind ...
Wobei, waren ja gar nicht nur die Amis,
das waren ja auch die Engländer, super heroisch und so.
Aber es war noch nicht so dieses ...
Alter, Krieg ist das Geilste überhaupt.
Es war schon sehr ...
Ja, wir sind die Geilsten,
aber es hatte noch so den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit irgendwie drüber.
Und das war danach weg.
Und deswegen finde ich es immer noch COD 4 das Beste.
Auch was den Multiplayer angeht,
das letzte große PC-Call of Duty war es ja letztendlich.
Ja.
Call of Duty 4 Modern Warfare
hat in der gesamten Shooter-Landschaft
seine Spuren hinterlassen.
Und das sowohl im Single wie auch im Multiplayer.
Das stimmt.
HP-Regeneration.
... ist bis heute Referenz für eine meisterhafte ...
Das stimmt, Beste.
... COD-Kampagne.
Ich finde immer noch die Beste.
... von Modern Warfare wurden über die Jahre so ausgelutscht,
dass wir mittlerweile drüber lachen.
Aber 2007 hat es die Leute eiskalt erwischt,
dass eure Spielfigur einfach mal so den Löffel abgibt,
weil plötzlich eine Atombombe am Horizont aufschlägt.
Missionen wie der AC-130-Flug in Death From Above
sorgten für Diskussionen.
Modern Warfare war manchmal auch unangenehm, unbequem.
Und im nächsten Moment wieder ein rasanter Actionfilm,
wie wir ihn bis dato noch nie gespielt hatten.
Von unvergesslichen Zitaten wie Soap,
was ist das überhaupt für ein Name?
... über die Tschernobyl-Mission
bis hin zum famosen Epilog-Level an Bord eines Flugzeugs.
Modern Warfare war im Singleplayer der Hammer.
Und im Multiplayer, da hat es mit seinem Progressionssystem ...
Das ist aber das Remaster, was man hier sieht.
Das ist nicht das Original-Cod 4, glaube ich.
Relativ sicher.
50.000 Leute lebten hier.
Ja, ich habe letztens Tschernobyl geguckt, die Serie.
Und ohne Scheiß, das Erste, woran ich denken musste,
als ... als ... bei der Kamera ...
Das Erste, woran ich denken musste, ist,
50.000 Leute lebten hier.
Und jetzt ist es eine Ghost Town.
... mit Level-Belohnungen und schnellen Infanterie-Gefechten
in vielerlei Hinsicht den modernen Shooter-Multiplayer geformt.
Noch zehn Jahre später kupferten Multiplayer-Spieler
die Methoden von Modern Warfare ein.
Und ja, die führten auch zu teils sehr aggressiven Monetarisierungen,
waren aber damals in erster Linie unheimlich motivierend,
weil selbst Neulinge immer wieder Hochgefühle erlebten
und Niederlagen sich nicht so blöd anfühlten.
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe in kaum einem Game so geraged
wie im Multiplayer hier, wenn irgendein Bullshit-Tode ...
Also, in Cod 4 weniger.
Aber in MW2 war ja ein Bullshit-Tode an der Tagesordnung.
Von Noobtubes, äh, Akimbo-Models.
Alles, ja.
Und nun zur großen Enthüllung großer Trommelwirbel.
Okay, wir hatten bis jetzt kein Half-Life.
Wenn da jetzt kein Half-Life dabei ist ...
Ich finde, die Liste bis jetzt gehe ich soweit sogar mit.
Nicht bei allem, würde ich sagen, das ist zu meinen Favoriten.
Aber wenn jetzt kein Half-Life kommt, Alter ...
Platz Nummer eins ...
Pass auf, jetzt kommt Portal oder so was, genau.
Das ist natürlich ...
Rambo the Video Game.
Der chibadet uns.
Der muss uns chibaden.
Falls euch dieses Video gefallen hat,
dann lasst ein Like und ein Abo da
und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Ich hab euch natürlich noch ...
Chibadet, das war klar.
Platz eins ist Half-Life 1.
Ja, Gott sei Dank, ey!
Ein Half-Life kennt man nicht.
Okay, jetzt ist die Liste von mir auch offiziell abgesegnet.
Nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwas ausmachen würde, aber ...
Jetzt ist die Liste von mir ...
Bestes Game, jawoll, sehe ich ganz genauso.
Half-Life veränderte damals, wie wir Shooter sehen.
Klar, das Ballern macht auch ...
Das ist aber mit den Blue-Shift-Waffenmodels,
die keiner mochte.
... Spaß, aber Half-Life war ein neuer Schritt.
Eine Evolution, ein Shooter, dessen Story, Atmosphäre und Welt ...
Ja, das ist mit den Blue-Shift-Models, die keiner mochte.
... richtig ernst nehmen konnte.
Ein Shooter, durch die Ego-Sicht,
also durch die Augen einer virtuellen Person erlebe.
Das sieht man auch an der Pistole.
Das sind die Blue-Shift-Models, die mochte niemand.
Ein Shooter, der mit einer langen und auch langsamen Zugfahrt beginnt,
mir seine Welt, sein Szenario zeigt,
statt mir direkt eine Pumpgun in die Hand zu drücken.
Gordon Freeman ist bis heute eine ...
Ich kann ... Warte mal.
... Story, Atmosphäre und Welt, man richtig ernst nehmen konnte.
Ein Shooter, durch die Ego-Sicht,
ein Shooter, der mit einer langen und auch langsamen Zugfahrt beginnt,
mir seine Welt, sein Szenario zeigt ...
Das wird der Zugfahrt.
Ich krieg heute ...
Ich krieg den Text immer noch ...
Also, ich krieg ihn nicht mal auswendig hin,
aber ich kann ihn immer noch mitsprechen.
Äh ...
Good morning and welcome to the Plagg-Mesa research ...
Nee, to the Plagg-Mesa transit system.
This automated train is inbound ...
Nee, ich krieg's nicht mehr hin.
Aber ...
Ähm ...
The time is ...
847 ...
with a topside temperature of ...
Keine Ahnung ...
85 degrees.
Also, ich krieg ...
Ohne Scheiß, ich krieg den Text heute immer noch
halbwegs aus dem Kopf zusammen.
Warte mal.
Äh ...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das findet.
Plagg-Mesa transit system.
Good morning and welcome to the Plagg-Mesa transit system.
This automated train is ...
It's provided by the security convenience
for the Plagg-Mesa research facility.
The time is ...
847 am.
Current topside temperature is ...
Ach, 93 degrees.
With an estimated time of 105.
The Plagg-Mesa ...
Ja, also, ich kann's nicht auswendig,
aber ich kann's auf jeden Fall mitreden immer noch,
mitsprechen immer noch.
Sektor C Testlabs.
... statt mir direkt eine Pumpgun in die Hand zu drücken.
Gordon Freeman ist bis heute
eine Legende unter den Gaming-Charakteren,
obwohl der Typ kein einziges Wort sagt.
Und genau das verrät euch,
welche Wirkung Half-Life damals hatte.
Ich war plötzlich kein Macho
mit einem Schrotgewehr,
sondern ein Wissenschaftler mit Brille und Laborkette.
Ein highly trained professional,
um genau zu sein.
... der in ein schrecklich missglücktes Experiment gerät
und in der Forschungsstation Black Mesa
ums Überleben kämpft,
während überall Aliens auftauchen
und meine eigene Regierung mich ausradieren will,
um Beweise zu vernichten.
Jeder Gegnertyp, jedes Areal von Half-Life
ist bis heute unvergesslich.
Und die beiden Add-ons Opposing Force
und Blue Shift runden das Ganze ab.
Generell hat Half-Life ähnlich wie Warcraft
im Strategie-Genre
ein gigantisches Erbe hinterlassen.
Ohne Half-Life gäbe es keinen Counter-Strike,
kein Team Fortress,
kein Day of Defeat, kein Portal,
ja vielleicht sogar nicht mal Steam.
Half-Life war...
Wahrscheinlich gäbe es nicht mal Steam.
Gunman war kein Add-on,
Gunman war ein Standalone-Game
von einem Mod-Entwickler,
den das dann sogar
von Valve selbst vertrieben wurde.
Und Gunman hat ein paar coole Sachen drinne gehabt,
zum Beispiel steuerbare Fahrzeuge.
Half-Life 1 hatte ja keine Steuern,
aber es gab ja auch
Half-Life 1 hatte ja keine steuerbaren Fahrzeuge.
Also du hattest Half-Life 1,
hattest du die...
Nein, Gearbox war Opposing Force.
Opposing Force war von Gearbox.
Gunman ist von...
irgendein Standalone-Ding gewesen
von irgendeinem anderen Hersteller.
Opposing Force war Gearbox.
Leute, mit Half-Life Knowledge
könnt ihr mich nicht...
Da kenn ich mich aus.
Das wollte ich jetzt noch sagen.
Genau, und Gunman hat
ein paar coole neue Sachen reingebracht.
Zum Beispiel steuerbare Fahrzeuge
hatte Half-Life nicht, weil das war
eine Limitierung aus der Quake 1 Engine,
dass du ein Entity in der Engine
konnte nur ein Fahrzeug
oder eine Waffe sein.
Du konntest nicht eine Waffe
und ein Fahrzeug sein.
Deswegen konntest du keine steuerbaren Panzer
in Half-Life machen.
Und dafür haben die Gunman-Leute
die Engine halb umgekrempelt
für die Steuerung, dass das möglich ist.
7K mit Half-Life 2
Ich glaube, Steam kam
ein Ticken
vor Half-Life 2.
Aber Half-Life 2
war der Steam-Seller quasi.
Und damals wurde sich drüber aufgeregt.
Oh, du brauchst Steam
und du musst dich online registrieren.
Oh, so scheiße.
Und heute ist es umgedreht.
Wenn heute ein Game nicht auf Steam rauskommt,
sagen die Leute, das kauf ich nicht,
das ist nicht auf Steam.
2003 haben die Leute gesagt, fuck Steam,
warum soll ich ins Spiel mit Steam?
Ein Spiel ohne Steam, Alter, kauf ich nicht.
Ein Fest für die Modding-Community
formte eine ganze Generation an Shooter-Fans,
bis zu dem Punkt, an dem ich mir kaum vorstellen kann,
wie die Gaming-Welt ohne Half-Life ausgesehen hätte.
Richtig, genau das denk ich mir auch.
So, und das waren sie,
unsere wissenschaftlich korrekten Top 10.
Jetzt seid ihr dran.
Geigt uns eure Meinung,
fordert eure Favoriten ein,
kritisiert unser Ranking,
aber vergesst dabei nie,
wir haben objektiv Recht,
denn solche Rankings...
Das hat er jetzt so oft so deutlich gesagt,
dass der letzte gecheckt haben sollte,
aber man muss das im Internet ja machen,
weil manche Leute checken es einfach nicht,
dass es nicht ernst gemeint ist.
Turok 2, Alter, das auf jeden Fall nicht,
auf jeden Fall nicht in den Top 10.
Es stört ihn, dass man nicht über Kimme und Korn ziehen kann,
meine Güte.
Soll an Half-Life mit dem Revolver spielen,
da geht das.
Aber, na gut, okay, Gamer von heute, ne?
Darf ich sagen, als...
Nee, das war ein PC-Spiel auf dem N64,
war das einfach nur richtig mies.
Der erste Teil hat auf dem N64
keine 2 Meter Sichtweite gehabt.
Aber, das war...
Das hat komplett...
Hier.
Das Spiel hat nur aus...
Du hattest 2 Meter Sichtweite auf dem N64, Alter.
Guckt euch das an.
Das bestand nur...
Wahrscheinlich,
weil ihr das nicht gesehen habt,
das bestand nur...
Wahrscheinlich, weil es der N64 nicht hinbekommen hat.
Das bestand nur aus...
Ja, ja.
Nur aus Nebel.
Und es hatte...
Roboter anstatt Menschen,
weil Nintendo sich gedacht hat,
oh, Menschen in Shootern, das geht ja nicht.
Wobei das witzigerweise bei Goldeneye auch kein Problem war.
Das darfst du fragen,
aber du bist nicht der Erste, der das gefragt hat.
Das haben schon ganz viele, ganz viele gefragt.
Und eigentlich sollten wir einen Bot haben,
der...
das beantwortet.
Ja, genau.
Da.
Response Skill.
Okay, aber nachdem er Half-Life 1 auf der Liste hat,
dann darf er da auch meinetwegen
Hunt Showdown und...
und...
Was hat er noch? Halo und Rainbow Six drin haben.
Wobei, Halo 2 lass ich mir gefallen,
aber Rainbow Six und Hunt Showdown, ich weiß nicht.
Na gut, aber, wie gesagt,
wie der will. Das haben wir ansonsten noch spannend,
das hier. Irgendwie nix, ne?
Fireship hat ein Video.
Stimmt, ich hatte hier sogar noch ein Fireship-Video auf.
Das haben wir gerade geguckt.
Ja.
Fireship hat noch ein Video.
Was... was ist denn das hier?
Die Deutsche Bahn macht auf dicke Hose.
Ah, das ist, ähm...
Ist das nicht Simplicissimus?
Zwei-Channel?
China-Schrott. Was taugt ein 80 Euro
10-Gigabit-Switch?
Ich glaube,
ich gehe davon aus, dass die Basics damit
durchaus funktionieren.
Advancedere Features,
Managed Features, wird man darauf umsonst
suchen, wenn man sie braucht. Und
wahrscheinlich ist die Geschwindigkeit
in der Backplane auch nicht allzu hoch.
Also, wenn jetzt beispielsweise mehrere
Geräte versuchen, das ordentlich
auszulassen an mehreren Ports,
dann wird es wahrscheinlich in die Knie gehen. Aber
ansonsten, für den Heimbereich dürften 80 Euro China
10-G
Switch... Was ist eigentlich
ein 10-G plus 2,5-G?
Also sprich, der hat
zwei 10-G-Uplinks und
den Rest 2,5, oder wie?
Das skippe ich mal kurz drüber, weil das
interessiert mich, was es da gibt.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Damen und Herren da draußen. Heute
widmen wir uns der großen Frage,
China-Schrott oder kein China-Schrott?
Der Fimien... Fimien-Switch.
Fimien-Switch.
China-Schrott halt eben
mal 2,5... Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Sag ich doch.
2-mal 10-G-Uplink und...
Nee.
Sixport. Ja.
Also das sind 2,5 und das sind 2-mal
10-G-Uplink. Ja, gut.
Fimien-Switch. Hatte jemand von euch
jemals schon einen Fimien-Switch?
Ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht, dass der Hersteller
überhaupt existiert.
...Switch, den wir
manchmal in irgendwelchen Haushalten brauchen,
wenn wir dann... Alles schon mal gehört, ne?
Das ist der große Netzwerkhersteller
unserer großen DCXen der
Internetinfrastruktur in Deutschland.
Und die bieten uns jetzt auf Amazon
diese Produkte an. Und ich hab mir gedacht, ich...
Fimien...
...Network
hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ja.
Okay. China-Chinesen-Zeug, was
niemand kennt.
Schauen wir das Ganze mal an, denn
preislich ist es sehr attraktiv. Bevor wir
das Ganze jetzt hier verdrahten, vielleicht wirklich, warum
das Ganze sehr attraktiv ist, da ist das Ganze
auf dem Karton auch nochmal richtig abgebildet.
Hier mit 6-mal 2,5
und 2-mal 10 GSFP+.
Also wirklich interessant für 2,5
sind tatsächlich nur die Kupferports.
2,5
mit Modulen oder
ja...
Dann machst du eher gleich auch 10.
Das sollten sie auch eigentlich mal da draufschreiben,
tun sie leider nicht. Und das Ganze halt
eben hier für 89,99
plus, da kann man gerade, wie ich das sehe, noch
einen 10-Prozent-Coupon-Gutschein
anklicken. Und ich kann euch sagen, wow.
Funktionieren tut erstmal alles. Aber
eine ganz wichtige Sache. Ich zeige euch...
Grundsprecher. Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
...gleich einmal hier in ganz, ganz groß.
Es gibt hier vorne ein ganz interess...
Ne, beides. Das sind 6 Ports. Guck.
Da 2. Äh, da 4.
Da 2. Das sind
Kupferports. Das hier sind für Module.
Da kannst du dann unter anderem Glasfaserkabel
an... Kommt halt aufs Modul an. Kannst du auch
Direct-Attach-Kabel dran schließen oder
Modul auf AJ45.
Ja. Halt je nachdem, was
du für ein Modul hast. Das sind schon 6 Ports.
Das trifft... Das stimmt schon.
Das sind halt auch die 10G.
Plus Ports. Ich zeige euch
das Foto jetzt auch gleich einmal hier in ganz, ganz groß.
Es gibt hier vorne einen ganz
interessanten Schieberegler.
Und da steht drauf einfach nur
WLAN on off. Fangen wir einfach
an mit dem Connect... Hä?
Ach, okay.
Wobei, äh, ergibt...
Ergibt trotzdem wenig
Sinn WLAN on off?
Ist das ein extra Management
Port? Weil ich meine,
wenn du ordentliche WLAN-Config damit
machen kannst, dann braucht es in irgendein
einer Art und Weise
Managementmöglichkeiten.
Was ist ein
VLAN? Man sollte, man sollte
es übrigens zur Deutlichkeit wahrscheinlich besser
VLAN aussprechen. Da ist damit gemeint.
Damit kannst du, um es ganz kurz
und ganz grob zu sagen, damit kannst du
aus einem physischen Switch zwei
machen. Ja? Also, du
könntest zum Beispiel einstellen.
Nehmen wir das mal hier.
Du könntest zum Beispiel sagen, okay,
Port 1 und 2
kommen in dieses
WLAN und Ports, keine Ahnung, in
WLAN 5 und Ports
3 und 4 kommen in WLAN 6
und da wird jeglicher Traffic,
der, äh, dort
reinkommt, ungetaggt, geht
ja nur ungetaggt, kriegt ein WLAN-Tag
drauf und kann dann nur innerhalb von diesem WLAN
kommen. Du machst dann quasi aus einem 4-Port-Switch
zwei 2-Port-Switche, wenn du das so willst.
Oder es ist halt sinnlos,
das machst du ja meistens bei größeren
Infrastrukturen. Und
obwohl du hier auf beiden Seiten
die gleichen, auf IP-Ebene dann,
die gleichen Netze vergeben könntest,
könnten die trotzdem nicht miteinander kommunizieren,
weil es eben zwei
unterschiedliche getrennte
WLANs sind. Das ist quasi
auf Layer 2 getrennt.
Oh, oh, sie Layer 2,
der Date, nee,
Data Link Layer,
gäh?
Please do not throw salami,
pizza, oh, okay, ja, Data Link
Layer. Das funktioniert folgendermaßen,
du hast in einem Ethernet
Frame
hast du einen
speziellen,
hast du ein spezielles Feld,
neben der Source- und Quell-Mac
hast du auch
noch ein Feld für WLAN-Tags.
Genau, hier hast du
einen WLAN-Tag drinnen.
Und hier bei Wikipedia steht's aber
super, super korrekt.
Ja. Ich hab da aber auch schon
schönere, hier sieht man
das schön, genau, ja.
Erkennung für Hardware, was
das in Ethernet-Frames jetzt kommt,
Destination-Mac-Adresse, Source-Mac-Adresse,
WLAN-Tag, Typ,
Data, genau, ja.
Layer 3, nein, Layer 2.
Layer 3 hat
das erst mal nichts zu tun.
Hast du ja auch gesehen, meine WLAN-Tag ist in einem Ethernet-Frame
und da sind wir uns ja einig, dass es Layer 2 ist.
Das kann man doch virtuelles
Subnetting nennen, nein.
Das hat mit Subnets nichts zu tun, da
spielen auch keine IP-Adressen und sonst
was eine Rolle. Ja, also
wenn du
zwei WLANs hast und du machst
irgendeinen, irgendeinen, ähm,
du würdest irgendeine Layer 2
Kommunikation machen, ja,
Destination-Mac-Adresse
angeben, sonst was, dann
würdest du den Broadcast schicken, den
würdest du auf der anderen Seite nicht sehen.
Das ist wirklich wie, wenn
du zwei getrennte Switches hättest.
Was wiederum geht, ist,
was wiederum geht, ist
Routen. Das ist dann kein
Problem. Also du kannst ohne Probleme
WLAN
von WLAN 5 nach WLAN 6
routen, wobei du nicht wirklich dann
WLAN routest, sondern
das ist dann halt eine Ebene oben
drüber, ja. Du hast dann dann irgendein
Netz A, Netz B, das geht zu
einem Router, wird weitergeleitet zum anderen.
Dem ist das dann egal, was unten drunter
für WLANs sind. Ja.
Aber im Prinzip kannst du da aus einem Switch
zwei mitmachen. Natürlich kannst
du damit noch deutlich mehr anstellen.
Äh. Natürlich kannst
du damit noch deutlich mehr anstellen, weil
ähm, normalerweise benutzt du das
ja nicht nur, um irgendwelche Switche
quasi zu trennen, um
die Geräte besser zu isolieren. Also
es ist zum Beispiel sinnvoll, wenn du WLAN Access
Points hast. Ja, du hast einen Kurs. Stellt euch mal
vor, ihr habt einen 24-Port-Switch.
Und
ihr wollt da beispielsweise auch eure
WLAN Access Points dran anschließen.
So, ihr wollt jetzt ja nicht unbedingt,
dass Geräte, die
im WLAN sind,
physisch gesehen schon,
wenn die Adressen stimmen würden, irgendwie mit
internen Geräten kommunizieren könnten.
Ja. Und dann würdest du das in dein eigenes
WLAN packen. Es wäre dann wie, wenn du einen eigenen
Switch hättest für die, für deine
WLAN Access Points zum Beispiel.
Allerdings muss man sagen,
werden die WLAN Tags
auch an die Clients gesendet? Nein.
Nein.
So pauschal nicht. Das
geht aber. Das nennt sich dann aber anders.
Also, es gibt zwei Varianten,
wie du das machen kannst.
Das Klassische, wie man das kennt,
da haben die Geräte keine Ahnung davon.
Die sehen den WLAN Tag auch.
Nicht.
Das ist eine reine Sache, die intern
im Switch gehandelt wird.
Der Traffic geht an den
Port rein. Dieser Port
ist getaggt mit
einem WLAN 5.
Ja. Dann wird das getaggt
am Eingang des Switches.
Daran weiß dann halt auch der Switch
im Weiteren, wie er das intern
switchen muss. Daran,
zu welchem WLAN das Ganze gehört. Und sobald
das das Gerät wieder verlässt,
sorgt dann aber auch dafür, dass es nicht aus
einem Port rausgehen kann, der in WLAN 6
ist, wenn es am Eingang als WLAN 5
getaggt wird. Und wenn das den Switch
verlässt, ist der WLAN Tag wieder weg.
So. Dann gibt es die Variante,
dass du eben
nicht das Transparent für Endgeräte
machst, sondern dass du das
äh, das wird
hauptsächlich benutzt für Kommunikation
von Switch zu Switch.
Dass du einen Trunk Port machst oder einen
Tagged Port oder einen Dingsport.
Jeder Hersteller nennt das ein bisschen anders.
Ein Dingsport ist das ganze Trunk.
Da läuft das so, dass
der WLAN Tag zwischen den Geräten
erhalten bleibt.
Und dann kannst du dann einstellen
zum Beispiel, auf diesem
Port ist WLAN
5, 15 und
25 erlaubt und solche Geschichten.
Das benutzt du oftmals zur
Kommunikation zwischen Netzwerkkomponenten.
Weil, du
willst ja vielleicht,
dass ein Telefon,
dass du hast, du hast
ein eigenes WLAN für Telefone,
WLAN 5 für Telefone, allerdings
hängt dein Telefon am Switch im dritten
Stock und deine Telefonanlage am Switch
im Keller. Und
da bringt es dir nichts, wenn die unabhängig
voneinander jeweils ein WLAN 5 haben.
Das muss getaggt, weitergegeben
werden, vom Switch im Keller zum Switch
im Verteilerraum im ersten
Stock und dann irgendwie hoch in den dritten
Stock oder so. So. Also das heißt, du
machst, du hast einmal das für Endgeräte
quasi am Port.
Das bedeutet,
sobald der Traffic reingeht, wird er getaggt
und sobald er rausgeht, wird der Tag wieder entfernt.
Das heißt, die Endgeräte merken davon nichts
und dann hast du das Ganze noch
taggt oder wie das Cisco nennt, als
als Trunk. Das benutzt du
hauptsächlich zur Kommunikation quasi
zwischen Netzwerkgeräten,
dass du eben
ja sowas machen kannst, wie Telefon kann mit der Telefonanlage
reden und sowas.
So, aber
das war jetzt recht
recht wirr und aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt,
aber so sieht es aus.
Wenn jemand, hier so als Tipp,
der Einstieg in Netzwerke, wenn jemand sich das
wirkliche Low Level angucken möchte,
wie da was passiert,
dann kann ich euch nur den Cisco
den Cisco Packet Tracer
empfehlen.
Das ist eine Software,
ja, sieht so aus, da kannst du selbst
Netzwerke zusammen klicken
und
mit dem Unterschied, dass du
das auch, das Netzwerk
in so einen
rundenbasierten Modus schalten kannst,
und quasi Package für Package
simuliert durchklicken kannst
und reinschauen kannst, wie sind
Header gesetzt, wie ist
Destination, wie ist Source,
was ist da wie getaggt?
Funktioniert das auch bei unterschiedlichen
Switch-Herstellern?
Du meinst, wenn du
Netzwerkgeräte verbinden willst,
die taggen, das
ja,
prinzipiell sollte das funktionieren auch
zwischen verschiedenen Herstellern.
Es funktioniert ja auch zwischen
zwischen der
Linux-Kiste und
einem Cisco-Switch zum Beispiel.
Ja, das, also,
das WLAN-Tag-Feld und sowas,
das ist standardisiert, aber Cisco hat natürlich
wieder eigenen Shit. Also,
das funktioniert prinzipiell, aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen, dass spezielle,
irgendwelche Spezial-Dinger
vielleicht nicht unterstützt werden. Ich meine, es funktioniert
zwischen einem Netzwerk-Endgerät und einer Linux-Kiste.
Du kannst ja auch eine Linux-Kiste
taggen,
wegdrehen lassen. Ja, du kannst zum Beispiel
auf einer Linux-Kiste
kannst du für deine
Netzwerkkarte, die kannst du
beispielsweise in fünf verschiedene
WLANs oder VLANs hängen.
Mit jeweils
unterschiedlichen MAC-Adressen dann.
Das funktioniert. Und das alles über
einen Anschluss. Wenn es nicht
taggt wäre, bräuchtest du fünf verschiedene Anschlüsse
und fünf verschiedene Netzwerkkarten im Endeffekt.
Oder fünf
verschiedene, naja,
ja, an fünf verschiedene Ports
ist es so dran. Ja, und das ist auch
was, was sich jeder Feezy merken sollte.
Das fragen sie bei der IHK
ganz gerne, was VLAN für ein Standard
ist.
Und das ist IEEE 802.
Ich wusste, dass
es Q ist, aber nicht, dass es Q1 ist.
Es gibt auch noch Ports.
Ist Ports-Security nicht auch irgendwas mit Q?
Wie dem auch sei.
Genug. Guck mal, ob
der Switch was taugt. Auch gleich einmal hier in ganz,
ganz groß. Es gibt hier vorne einen
ganz interessanten Schieberegler.
Und da steht drauf einfach nur
VLAN on off.
Fangen wir einfach an mit dem... Lernen wir in der Ausbildung
BGP? Ne, also
weiß ich nicht, ob man das heute nicht lernt.
Ich vermute das nicht. Wir haben das damals nicht gelernt.
Wir haben OSPF
gelernt in der Ausbildung.
Also ich rede jetzt von
einer Berufsschule. Ja, in der Ausbildung kommt es
darauf an. Wenn du
bei einem Provider arbeitest
oder bei irgendwas, dann kann das durchaus sein.
Ich habe damals ja meine Ausbildung
bei einem Provider gemacht. Also ich habe
kein BGP direkt gelernt. Also ich
durfte nie, ich durfte nie beispielsweise
irgendwelche,
irgendwelche Sachen umruten BGP
mäßig. Aber
wir haben OSPF gemacht intern
damals bei uns im Netz. Und ich habe
OSPF
OSPF in der Ausbildung gelernt.
OSPF, sag mal, es gibt ja zwei Unterschiede.
OSPF wird ganz gerne intern benutzt,
aber wenn es zwischen, Austausch zwischen
verschiedenen Providern,
Carriern, was auch immer geht, dann ist
es ja BGP weltweit.
So, und ob man das heute lernt, weiß ich
nicht, weil ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was es ist.
Aha.
Virtual Extensible
Laden, was auch immer.
T-Check.
Hier steht die Kiste, angeschlossen ist sie.
OSPF ist dead, warum?
Machen die coolen Leute
heute?
Ich glaube, Boot, hochfahren
oder gebootet ist die Kiste in
drei Sekunden oder irgendwie sowas.
Weil Management gibt es sowieso nicht bei der
Kiste, aber jetzt ist die große Frage,
wofür ist der Schalter, der hier vorne ist?
Ihr seht, das ist hier mein Eingangsnetz, kommt von meinem
Switch, das schwarze Kabel geht hier ganz
normal zu meinem PC und wie wir hier sehen
Was hat er eigentlich im Hintergrund da für ein Ding
laufen? Irgendein Grafana mit
irgendwelchen
Requests oder so?
Ist das ein Request von irgendeinem Webservice oder sowas?
Kommt von meinem Switch, das schwarze Kabel geht hier
ganz normal zu meinem PC und wie wir hier
sehen, Ethernet 4, Netzwerk
22, ich hole euch das Fenster hier rüber,
sehen wir, ich habe eine ganz normale
Verbindung, ich habe auch eine ganz normale IP
Was er betreibt, ein dünn DNS-Dienst.
Doch jetzt kommt die ganz, ganz große Frage,
wofür ist der Schieberegler?
Der halt eben sagt, wie landet On-Off?
Ich drehe ihn jetzt einmal. Bin auch gespannt.
Wofür ist der Schieberegler? Ihr seht,
die LEDs sind gerade kurz ausgegangen.
Der rebootet jetzt bestimmt. Die leuchtet irgendwie
andauernd und immer, aber vorne jetzt
vom Link her und so weiter gehen die LEDs
jetzt gleich erst wieder an und wir sehen
jetzt auch schon am PC, ah, er hat es jetzt gerade
schon gemacht, er ist schon wieder hochgefahren.
Ich sage ja, Bootzeit ist einfach unfassbar von
diesem Ding, aber es kommt jetzt nichts mehr.
Und nach vielen Tüfteln hin oder her
habe ich einfach festgestellt, alles klar,
dieses WLAN, und das steht auch irgendwo
in diesen Tiefen auf der Amazon-Seite,
ist eigentlich nichts anderes als
eine Isolation zwischen
diesen vier 2,5G-Ports.
Das heißt aber...
Also sprich, sprich, die haben dann
WLAN 5, 6, 7, 8
oder wie vergeben die dann?
Und deswegen liegt ja auch der 10G
SFP. Wobei, wie das intern tanken,
ist ja wurscht. Anschließend packt ihr
ihn hier rein, steckt ihn einfach in einen
der SFP-Slots rein
und jetzt wird die Kiste natürlich quasi wieder
einmal hochfahren und dann werdet ihr jetzt sehen,
dass wir jetzt gleich ganz normal zwischen
meinem PC und dem SFP Plus
dort wieder einen Link kriegen und ich auch eine IP-Adresse
bekomme. Wir schauen kurz rüber, haben
wir da Netzwerk 22, ich mache
das Ganze wieder auf, wunderbar.
Ich ziehe das Fenster für euch ja wieder rum.
Ist dann auch wieder so ein typisches missverständlicher
Schalter an irgendeinem China-Ding.
Hopp, wunderbar. 4021.
Also wir haben jetzt also wieder ganz normal
ein Netzwerk-Interface bzw. eine IP-Adresse
bekommen. Das heißt, dieser komische
WLAN-Schalter hier drauf ist
nichts anderes, um halt eben diese vier Ports
voneinander zu isolieren,
werden aber weiter ganz
normal auf die zwei
SFP-Ports drauf geswitcht. Das
heißt, und das ist auch glaube ich der größte Anwendungsfall,
wenn ihr da draußen mal auf der
Suche seid nach einem Medien-Converter,
ich glaube, das ist mit einer der großen
Anwendungsfälle für den Preis ist
das definitiv sofort
ein Anwendungsfall, der mir auf jeden Fall einfällt.
Das Einzige, was wir bis hierhin nicht testen können,
weil auch ich hier nur ein Gigabit hier habe,
ein Gigabit nur hier habe, ist halt eben
irgendwo die Performance. Deswegen werde ich jetzt das
Schätze-Card mit runternehmen. Ach guck mal, der hat auch
so ein gutes, günstiges
MikroTik
RJ45 auf
SFP-Plus-Modul.
Da habe ich auch ein paar da.
Sehr praktisch, sowas zu haben.
Runter in mein Homelab nehmen. Wobei ich weiß nicht,
ob es ein MikroTik-Modul ist. Es gibt ja noch andere günstige.
Wo ich halt eben ein bisschen mehr 10G liegen habe.
Ich habe mir damals so ein 10er-Pack gekauft,
MikroTik-Module.
Die sind nur
ein Gigabit,
aber kosten auch nicht viel, aber
sind sehr praktisch, wenn man beispielsweise Switche
hat, die
mehr SFP-Plus-Ports haben als
RJ45-Ports und man braucht mal wieder einen
RJ45-Port.
Wenn ich einen 40G-Server angeschlossen habe, wird das Ganze
mal verdrahten und dann schauen wir einfach mal, ob wir
einfach über diese Kiste hier mal
einen Iperf drüber jagen können, bevor
wir dann gleich ein Fazit ziehen.
So, kommen wir schnell zu meinem
Versuchsaufbau. Da steht die Kiste.
Ich habe die ganz normal mit einem DAC-Kabel
hier auf meinen MikroTik-Switch verbunden
auf Port 22 und hier
einfach mit dem 2,5G-Kabel
geht es hier hoch.
DAC ist ein Direct
Attach-Kabel.
Das ist im Prinzip ein kurzes
Kabel mit Kupferleitung drinne,
hat aber auf beiden Seiten schon
SFP-Plus-Modulstecker dran.
Ist auch das beste und günstigste
und einfachste, wenn man
beispielsweise einen
Fileserver-Lokal hat
oder eine NAS mit 10G
und das möchte man
an einen 10G-Switch anschließen.
Das ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Spart man sich teure 10G-Module
und macht keinen Unterschied.
Und ist wahrscheinlich sogar
ein bisschen stromsparender noch.
Meine Teststation, wo halt eben
ich glaube sechs Platten drin sind,
wo einfach ein paar Testdaten drauf liegen,
die mit 2,5G natürlich sprechen kann.
Und das heißt, wir werden es gleich versuchen,
unten vom Server aus, werden wir
jetzt gleich einfach versuchen eine Kommunikation zu machen.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert, was für einen krassen
Stromverbrauch die Leute daheim haben.
Ich meine, ich gehe immer schon darauf,
dass mein Aufbau schon ein bisschen übertrieben ist.
Ich meine, jeder, der einen Rack
bei sich daheim stehen hat, der übertreibt es ja
am meisten schon.
Aber das ist nicht ohne hier. Wobei das meiste, glaube ich,
auch aus ist.
Und dann ganz normal über den Switch.
Wenige Augenblicke später
melde ich mich wieder zurück.
Gut und günstige Netzwerkmodule.
Ja, ich habe mir damals bei Amazon relativ günstig
Mikrotik, SFP Plus, aber nur ein, nicht SFP Plus.
Ja, genau. Allerdings 29 Euro, die gab es damals relativ günstig.
Die gab es damals für, ich glaube, irgendwie 12 Euro
oder so das Stück.
Und gucken wir mal, was die haben.
Ja, das sind 10G-Module, die sind natürlich teuer.
fs.com, ich habe, nee, ich habe fs.com-Module auch.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob ich bei denen auf der Seite bestelle.
Haben die hier einen gescheiten Filter?
Ich würde gerne einen Filter auf einen Gigabit setzen,
falls das möglich ist.
Nein, ich will bis ein Gigabit haben.
Ja, Filter nach.
Mein Gott, ist die Seite kacke.
30 Euro.
Da dürften bei Modulen nicht allzu viel, ja, okay.
Aber die Dinger sind echt teuer geworden, ne?
25 Euro, ich glaube, ich habe damals, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaube, ich habe damals 12 Euro oder so was bezahlt.
Amazon.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich die bei Amazon gekauft habe.
Vielleicht finde ich die da jetzt auch nicht.
Äh, Mic.
Nee, habe ich nicht bei Amazon gekauft, sieht man nicht.
Sieht man nicht.
Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Aber er ist auf einer MikroTik-Kiste.
Zumindest auf dem Switch.
Schon mal sehr gute Wahl, dass er sich einen MikroTik-Switch gekauft hat,
als Main-Unit.
War er nicht sonst immer Ultra-Unify-Fan
und hat alles Mögliche von Ubiquiti gehabt?
Die Dinger hier sind mega.
Also preis-leistungsmäßig sind die meisten MikroTik-Sachen wirklich gut.
... die WLAN-Skolle figuriert, die ich fürs TrueNAS brauche.
Ihr seht, ich habe gerade schon mal den ersten Test gemacht,
dass zumindest die Kommunikation steht.
Das funktioniert soweit und wir können auch sehen,
ich kann mich ganz normal auf mein System dort einwählen.
Ich habe auch das jetzt extra mal auf,
damit wir auch von dieser Sicht einfach ein bisschen
die Performance-Sicht einfach haben.
Wir fangen jetzt mit dem Alleraller-Einfachsten an.
Das Ganze ist ja, habe ich auch gerade gezeigt,
an meinem Server verbunden, zumindest einfach mal
als Backup-Destination.
Also ich gehe ganz davon aus,
2,5G ist für das Ding überhaupt kein Problem.
Fraglich wird es dann nur,
bei so billig-schienen Geräten,
wie ist das, wenn mehrere Geräte 10 oder 2,5G machen?
Weil das zwischen zwei Endgeräten einmal 2,5G laufen kann,
das sollte eigentlich kein Ding sein.
Aber was die Backplane wirklich schafft,
wenn da mal beispielsweise an allen Ports es ordentlich brummt,
dann muss man sich das schon anderweitig angucken.
So, einfach mal von der 101 hier starten wir jetzt einfach mal
ein Backup.
Das finde ich bei MikroTik übrigens auch ganz gut.
Ich schaue mir das immer an.
Wenn man beispielsweise mal MikroTik, keine Ahnung,
irgendwie sowas hier guckt,
dann kann man bei den hier Testresultaten,
kann man sich angucken, Switching Performance mit Framegrößen
und irgendwo im Handbuch steht dann auch ziemlich genau drin,
was die für eine Bandbreite auf der Backplane haben.
Finde ich gut gemacht, ja.
Also da weißt du genau, auf was du dich einlässt.
Bei so China-Dingern eher nicht.
Aber gut, dafür sind sie billig.
Ein NAS-Share, was hier angegeben ist, ihr seht schon...
Er hat alles durchprobiert und ist dann bei MikroTik angekommen.
Ja, gut.
Dann haben wir da ähnliche Entwicklungen gemacht.
Ich hatte ja auch einige Sachen durchprobiert,
aber vor Jahren schon bin ich dann mal bei MikroTik gelandet,
was einfach eine super Kombination ist aus Möglichkeiten,
die du hast, kannst ja damit erst alles machen,
wenn auch nicht immer so ganz klar in der Konfiguration.
Und Preis-Leistung.
MikroTik hat aber, finde ich, die letzten zwei, drei Jahre
ein bisschen nachgelassen mit den Geräten.
Beispielsweise gibt es von MikroTik immer noch keine gescheiten 2,5G-Switche,
die sich so richtig lohnen würden.
Da müssen wir mal gucken hier, Filter.
Konnte man aber nicht mehr filtern als nur New und Range?
Das ist ja Müll.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, MikroTik hat immer noch keine wirklich guten,
attraktiven 2,5G-Switche und so was.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Wenn man 10G oder 40 sucht, sind die wieder gut,
aber die haben ein bisschen nachgelassen die letzten Jahre über.
Du kannst dann 10G-Switche auch 2,5 anschließen, ja.
Aber es wäre halt richtig cool, wenn die in den günstigen,
sagen wir mal, 24 Ports 2,5G und so was hätten.
Das wäre mega nice.
Haben sie aber nicht.
Er resümt schon die VM und wir gucken jetzt einmal.
Da seht ihr schon, 250 Megabyte die Sekunde.
In ganz klein sieht man es hier.
In ganz klein, 260.
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen, das Maximum bei 2,5G dürfte 312 oder so was sein.
Weiß ich nicht.
Irgendwie sowas.
Gigabit to Megabyte.
Wollen wir mal.
Ey, Leute.
Leute.
Nicht schlecht, oder?
Nicht schlecht.
Müsst ihr zugeben.
Oh, das sind 25 Gigabit.
Sekunde.
Also für Kopf, ganz im Ernst, nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, ich habe ein bisschen gecheatet.
Das heißt, dass es 125 MB sind für ein Gigabit.
Habe ich das zusammengerechnet.
Dann irgendwie nochmal 60, bloß ein bisschen was drauf.
Aber 312.
Aber für Kopf war das nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das wird mit Sicherheit ganz normal die 2,5G sein.
Wenn wir jetzt auf der Seite hier schauen.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder so einen Schwall sehen.
Eher anstatt halt eben eine durchgehende Verbindung.
Das ist von Proxmox, vom Backup her, eigentlich ziemlich typisch,
dass das Ganze so abläuft.
Das werden wir auch auf dem Switch sehen.
Momentan seht ihr ja.
Ja, ein Proxmox Backup.
Weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist als Switch-Test.
Große Files auf SSDs kopieren IPerf oder sonst was.
Oder Dings hier.
Wie heißt das?
Wie heißt diese IPerf-Alternative?
Die von BSD.
Auch ganz...
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, das meine ich alles nicht.
Das meine ich.
Das meine ich, ja.
Na ja, gut. Schauen wir mal.
Wenn wir jetzt einmal auf den Switch schauen.
Warum ich Windows 11 benutze?
Das ist ganz einfach zu erklären.
Ich habe gar keinen großartigen Bock gehabt auf Windows 11.
Genau. Richtig.
Meine CPU...
Windows 11 ist das erste Windows, was meine CPU ordentlich unterstützt.
Das macht unterm Strich nicht wirklich viel Performance aus.
Aber ich...
Mir widerstrebt es, ein OS zu verwenden,
das meine CPU nicht richtig unterstützt.
Ach, Microsoft will viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Da haben wir es auch.
Da unten müsst ihr mal gucken, wo meine Maus ist.
Da unten, wo meine Maus sich dreht.
Da seht ihr auch immer.
Es kommt immer nur so schwallartig.
Ja, okay.
Die Kunde ist aber natürlich...
Minus Client.
Dann sagen wir hier...
Zeig mal her.
Wie gesagt, der Test ist gut.
Wunderbar.
Man kann...
Also, was ich gut fände, wenn man es jetzt noch auf mehreren Ports gleichzeitig testen würde.
Zum Beispiel per 10G was anschließen.
Und dann von mehreren Rechnern IPerf machen auf das 10G-Interface.
Da muss man nämlich mal gucken, was wirklich über die Backplane drüber geht.
Das ist bei den China-Chinesen-Dingern wahrscheinlich nicht viel mehr als 2,5G mit den Ports.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du noch nicht mal mit dem Ding 10G machen zwischen den zwei 10G-Ports.
Und jagen einfach mal einen Single-Stream los.
Also ganz normal, ohne Parallel, ohne irgendwas großartig anzugeben, wie viel.
Und ihr seht, wir landen...
Also die Retries bei TCP-Verbindungen machen mir jetzt schon ein bisschen Sorgen.
Bei UDP ist das relativ normal, dass du zwar keine Retries hast, aber...
Datenverlust, wenn du nicht genau die Buffergröße und Netzwerk-Bandbreite einstellst, scheint mir ein wenig viel Retries zu sein.
Hier auf den 2,35 Gigabit.
Das ist auch das, das kann ich euch sagen.
Ich habe das schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Da habe ich immer gelandet bei 112...
Ich meine, das ist nicht wild, muss man sagen.
2,5G und ein paar Retries, überhaupt kein Ding.
Bei normalen Geschwindigkeiten juckt null.
Kann ich euch sagen.
Ich habe das Ganze schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Und das liegt jetzt nicht daran, muss man nämlich auch sagen.
Leute sagen immer, oh Packet, lost Packet.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich daran, weil das wird halt einfach gedroppt, weil an irgendeiner Stelle irgendwelche Buffer voll sind.
Oder irgendwie das nicht mehr angenommen werden kann.
Kein, oh, Kabel kaputt retry oder so.
Wenn er die Geschwindigkeit ein bisschen runterschrauben würde, hätte er wahrscheinlich null Retries.
Oder ganz wenige Retries.
Darf man nicht davon ausgehen, dass wenn man jetzt Gigabit darüber überträgt, das Ding auf einmal laufend irgendwas neu anfordern muss.
Gigabit, das ist auch das, das kann ich euch sagen.
Ich habe das Ganze schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Da habe ich immer gelandet bei 112.
Also man ist nie an die vollen 125.
Wer macht das auch?
Vielleicht sieht man mal 120.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe auf der Kiste immer ein bisschen...
...weniger gesehen gehabt.
Es waren so 112, aber dafür durchgehend und gerade.
Und hier sehen wir gerade das Vergleichbare, dass wir nicht ganz die 250 sehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, 280 Megabytes pro Sekunde ist schon der Knaller.
So, wir können jetzt einfach mal angeben, parallel 16.
Mal gucken, ob die Kiste auch damit zurande kommt.
Und auch ja, das kann ich sagen, 2,35 Gigabit laufen jetzt hier wieder ganz normal durch.
Wie sieht es aus, wenn wir diesen ganz normalen Befehl jetzt einfach mal auf die UDP-Basis umbauen?
Und ich drücke jetzt hier einfach mal 10 Gigabit.
UDP, gerade bei diesem Packet, bei diesen Tests, hast du immer ziemlich viel Traffic, der verloren geht.
Also IPerf ordentlich UDP zu testen, finde ich, ist tatsächlich gar nicht so easy.
Weil du hast ja da keinen Mechanismus von Retries.
Das kommt einfach nicht an, wenn du ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite schickst.
Und auch, wenn du es nicht genau tunest an die Buffergröße von deinem OS...
Und vielleicht dann auch noch die Framegröße ein bisschen hochschraubst, ist es schwierig, das zu saturaten alles.
Weil Framegröße hochschrauben geht ja gar nicht so ohne weiteres, wenn es nicht beide Seiten unterstützen.
Geh irgendwie mal Reverse durch.
Mal gucken, hoffentlich war der Befehl der richtige.
Guck, guck!
Da sehen wir jetzt auch 2,3...
Guck hier, 31%, 12%, 32% Daten verloren.
IPerf und UDP ist immer so ein Ding, wo du als Netzwerktechniker erst mal Anfälle kriegst, weil du denkst, dein Netzwerk ist kaputt.
Macht 2,10%.
Ist es aber gar nicht.
Das flappt jetzt rum, weil ich gerade auch gesagt habe, 10G.
Also die andere Seite versucht jetzt gerade 10G da durchzupumpen mittels UDP.
Und das kommt halt eben nicht an.
Ich kann jetzt auch nochmal dieses Reverse hier weglassen.
Dann sehen wir jetzt hier auf der Seite wahrscheinlich, wie ich sagte, deutlich mehr.
Aber wenn wir jetzt auf der anderen Seite schauen, da kann halt auch keiner...
Er pumpt hier unten jetzt gerade 4G raus.
Auf der anderen Seite kommt noch 2,3 rein.
Also auch UDP funktioniert in diesem Falle hier wirklich ganz normal und auch problemlos.
Und damit will ich eigentlich auch zum Fazit kommen.
Du würdest gerne Linux benutzen, aber es funktioniert nichts.
Dann bleibt dir nur Arch Linux übrig.
Weil Arch Linux einfach das Beste ist, was es gibt.
Da verstehst du zwar auch nichts als Einsteiger, aber du kannst immerhin sagen, dass du Arch Linux benutzt.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist zwar wirklich ein Stück Blech, was quasi nichts kann.
Vielleicht eine Isolierung von den Ports, wer es braucht, okay.
Aber ganz ehrlich, aus meiner Sicht, für die Leute, die dann doch wirklich, wirklich 2,5G haben wollen...
Also mich hätte jetzt interessiert, wenn man das über mehrere Ports macht, um zu wissen, was wirklich drüber geht.
Ja, aber ansonsten bestimmt ein ganz günstiger, gescheiter Switch.
Freitag geht meine Ausbildung los.
Als was denn?
Warst du mal auf der Gamescom dieses Jahr nicht?
Du meinst mal, ja.
Ich war sogar schon auf der...
Ich war mehrere Male auf der Gamescom und ich war sogar auf der Gamesconvention in Leipzig damals.
Aber ich war die letzten Jahre schon nicht mehr auf der Gamescom.
Jo, einfach weil es sich irgendwie nicht lohnt.
Und anstrengend ist und nervig ist.
Mittlerweile...
Mittlerweile wird man ja angeblich von Security-Leuten umgerannt, wenn man bei ihm in die Nähe kommt.
Das war damals noch nicht so.
Hast du das mit dem Flitzer mitbekommen auf der Opening-Show?
Nein, habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Aber witzig, dass es jetzt sowas wohl nicht nur beim Fußball gibt, sondern auch auf der Gamescom.
Das, was ich persönlich an der Gamescom immer sehr nice fand, ist, dass es einfach so eine komplett eigene Welt ist.
Mal für ein paar Tage, wie lange man da ist.
Dass man mal Leute sieht, die man sonst nur online kennt.
Das war für mich auch immer so die...
Obwohl ich es ja ansonsten mit so sozialen Sachen nicht habe.
Das war für mich auch immer so das Highlight an der Gamescom.
Dass man mal ein paar Leute gesehen hat, die man von YouTube kennt.
Mit denen man vielleicht sogar online schon mal was aufgenommen hat, aber nicht in echt oder selten in echt sieht.
Das fand ich immer cool.
Der Games-Aspekt auf der Gamescom.
Und wir hatten damals ja auch tatsächlich, außer nach dem ersten Mal Gamescom, wo man es ein bisschen verpeilt hat, haben wir das auch immer ordentlich vorbereitet.
Ich bin ja da nie allein hingefahren.
Meistens waren wir insgesamt zwei, drei Leute.
Und...
Also auch Leute noch von YouTube dabei.
Wo wir dann im Vorfeld Termine gemacht haben mit den Herstellern und uns verabredet haben.
Dementsprechend hatten wir auch immer ein ziemlich volles Programm.
Aber es war trotzdem ätzend voll.
Der einzig ertragbare Tag an der Gamescom für mich, der angenehm war, war Mittwoch, war das, glaube ich, früher.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch Mittwoch.
Wo es halt diesen einen Tag gab, wo noch nicht so voll war.
Ja.
Und ansonsten konntest du dich ja kaum von A nach B bewegen.
Und ich stell mir halt gerade vor, Gamescom muss richtig anstrengend sein, wenn du keine Termine im Vorfeld gemacht hast.
Und einfach zwei Stunden warten musst.
Ich kam mir ja richtig assi vor, ja.
Wir waren damals bei Nvidia, da war die...
Was war denn das?
Könnte es noch nur Oculus Rift gewesen sein damals?
Nvidia hatte damals einen VR-Stand, wo es diese Portal-Demo gab.
Die haben bestimmt einige von euch gesehen, die Portal-VR-Demo.
Die war richtig gut.
Und da haben wir so eine Eintrittskarte bekommen.
Wir waren bei Nvidia und die haben gesagt, hey, wart ihr schon bei unserem VR-Stand?
So, nee, wussten wir gar nicht, dass ihr einen habt.
Ja, hier, kommt, kriegt ihr eine Eintrittskarte, geht da einfach hin, zeigt die, dann könnt ihr euch das angucken.
Da sind wir da halt hin und das war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt um den Nvidia-Stand.
Also normalerweise hast du ja immer so einen Gamescom-Stand.
Und da steht dann Schlange bis hierhin und beim Nvidia-Stand für die VR-Brille war die Schlange dreimal um den Stand gewickelt.
Die war dreimal länger, als es sein sollte.
Und das kam mir schon damals richtig assi vor.
Da sind wir an dem Stand vorbeigegangen, haben gesagt, oh cool, würde ich mir gerne mal angucken.
Wir haben ja hier die Karte gekriegt, sollen wir einfach am Stand vorbeigehen?
Bin ich mit der Karte halt zum Nvidia-Stand und die haben gesagt, ja, kommt mit rein.
Und da haben die uns halt da vorbeigeführt an irgendwie Leuten, die dann am 3 Stunden oder am 2,5 Stunden Wartemarker standen.
Habe ich mir schon irgendwie ein bisschen doof vor, ja.
Deswegen war ich immer ganz froh, wenn diese ganzen Termine nicht an den gleichen öffentlichen Ständen waren.
Oder diesen kleinen Abteil hatten, bei Blizzard war das so, für Hearthstone damals.
Da hat es so eine Ecke, da wurde es dann an der Seite reingeschleust.
Das kam mir immer echt blöd vor, wenn du da vorbeigeführt wurdest und irgendwie Leute stehen da 2,5 Stunden an und du wirst dann auch doof angeguckt von allen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Dafür kriegst du damit nicht, du musst dich im Vorfeld wirklich darum kümmern und Termine machen.
Du kannst nicht einfach mit einem Ausweis da hingehen und sagen, hallo, ich bin der Max, ich will da gerne rein. Ne, ne.
Also reine Presseakkreditierung oder sowas für die Gamescom bringt dir nichts.
Du musst im Vorfeld wirklich Termine mit den Herstellern machen.
Sonst hört das nichts.
Gut, wenn die auf so einem Termin dann die Hersteller irgendeinen Ausweis in die Hand drücken oder irgendein Eintrittsding für ihren Stand, wo die das geregelt haben.
Es gibt ja Leute, die haben solche Pässe dann kopiert, habe ich gehört.
Erinnert sich noch jemand? Fastpass-Kopieraktion.
Da gab es richtig, da ging es richtig zur Sache.
Luku, dankeschön.
Ah, du hast dich umbenannt, gell?
Ich erkenne es, du hast dich wieder umbenannt.
Danke für den Sub.
Genau, ja.
Was da gelaufen ist im Hintergrund, man.
Ich weiß ja heute immer noch nicht, wem ich das, wem ich das, die Story da glauben soll.
Ja, also egal, ist so lang, ja.
Groove Electric, POG-Subskription.
Leute, bald ist soweit, bald ist wieder der erste, da werden alle Prime-Subs frei.
Twitch-Usernamen mit Bedacht wählen.
Oh, Bezos muss ins Weltall, Leute.
Noch was anderes.
Wenn euch mein Content auf Twitch gefällt, ich will gar nicht Prime-Subscribed werden.
Natürlich auch, habe ich keine Schmerzen mit, ja.
Aber wenn es euch gefällt, könnt ihr mir auch gerne followen.
Ist auch schon sehr nice.
Macht er, ich habe keine Ahnung, keinen Schimmer mehr, ob der überhaupt noch was macht.
Nee.
Der war doch mal zwischendrin so im Poker-Game am Start.
Dubai, man, Alter.
Was machen die da alle?
Muss man doch wenig Steuern bezahlen.
Leute, ich muss heute echt ein Video aufnehmen.
Wird mir echt wieder Zeit.
Rambo ist wieder aktiv.
Meine Güte.
Nee, das mache ich nicht auf YouTube.
Ja, habe ich schon.
Ja, ja, habe ich schon.
Das wird übelster, übelster G-Bait-Titel.
Wobei, mit einem Funken Wahrheit dabei, natürlich.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe Hunger.
WilderIgel, 50 Milliarden.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was denn?
Schaltet man denn die Animationen auf Twitch frei?
Oder kann man die, ich habe noch nie Bits gegiftet.
Kann man die beim Bits giften auswählen?
Ich würde sagen, nimm gar keine Kubernetes-Installer-Geschichten.
Finde ich total unsinnig.
Ja, trinken habe ich gerade schon.
Aber schön, dass du mich erinnerst.
Heute waren wir nicht sonderlich produktiv.
Ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft.
Leute, ich glaube, haben wir es geschafft,
in drei Stunden drei Videos zu gucken oder so?
Heute gibt es keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Tomatensauce und Hackfleisch.
Kubernetes updaten ist gar nicht so einfach.
Also zumindest, wenn es bei Cloud-Anbietern ist.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es bei Selbstinstalliertem auch so ist.
Aber ich glaube, dass es auch so ist.
Da hatte ich noch nie so ein komplett outdated Kubernetes.
Du kannst ja nicht von irgendeiner alten Version auf eine neue Version updaten.
Du musst von einer alten Version auf eine alte Version,
auf eine alte Version, auf eine alte Version,
auf eine nicht mehr ganz so alte Version
und dann irgendwann mal auf eine neue supportende Version.
Ist aber auch verständlich.
Die haben so viele neue Sachen an Resource Types und so, was sie supporten
und was dann irgendwie umgestellt wird.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Bei Google ist es relativ easy.
Wenn du einen Managed Google Kubernetes Cluster hast,
der wird zwangsgeupdatet.
Du hast gar keine Chance, da rauszukommen.
Du kannst die Updates deaktivieren einmalig für 30 Tage.
Aber danach kriegst du zwanghaft ein Update aufgedrückt,
ob du willst oder nicht.
Finde ich aber auch gut.
Dann machen sich erstens die Leute Gedanken darauf,
wie sie ihre Anwendungen darauf laufen lassen,
sodass die Anwendung auch mal einen Restart überlebt.
Weil eine Anwendung, die in Kubernetes läuft,
die keinen Restart überlebt, ist halt für einen Arsch.
Und du hast nicht das Problem, dass du irgendwann komplett outdated bist.
Oder die Leute gehen zu AKS.
Da kriegen sie aber meiner Ansicht nach
den schlechteren Managed Kubernetes.
Wobei AKS auch in Ordnung ist.
Ich kannte AKS vor Google Kubernetes,
weil wir bei der alten Firma hauptsächlich Azure hatten.
Aber ich muss sagen, insgesamt gefällt mir das Paket besser von Google.
Also mir gefällt GKE besser.
Am schlechtesten ist ja wohl EKS.
Vom Hörensagen habe ich selbst...
Also Azure... ähm... ja, ja... äh... AWS.
EKS ist der Kubernetes-Server von AWS.
Weil Elastic Kubernetes, glaube ich.
Vom Hörensagen her soll der der schlechteste sein von allen drei.
Ja, das ist sicherlich sehr, sehr abartig.
Ich mache ja auch hauptsächlich aktuell Kubernetes,
und zwar im Google-Umfeld.
Und so langsam aber sicher, muss ich ehrlich sagen...
Ich meine, ich kannte mich schon, bevor ich dort angefangen habe,
ganz brauchbar damit aus.
Aber gerade so Feinheiten kriegt man erst raus,
wenn man das wirklich täglich benutzt.
Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens herausgefunden,
es gibt einen Service-Typ in Kubernetes,
der einen DNS-Alias setzen kann.
Was mega praktisch ist,
wenn du für alle Cluster-Ressourcen
den gleichen Namen verwenden möchtest.
Ja, wenn du für alle Cluster-Ressourcen
den gleichen Namen verwenden möchtest,
in unterschiedlichen Umgebungen, ja.
Stell dir mal vor, man hätte ein Testing,
ein Testing und ein Live-Environment
und möchte im Cluster selbst die Umgebung
die gleichen Namen verwenden für externe Dienste.
Ja, dann kannst du beispielsweise einen Service setzen,
der einen DNS-Alias im Cluster anlegt und so.
Das ist schon wirklich...
Also, da kommt man aber erst drauf,
wenn man es eine Weile verwendet hat.
Da würde ich dem AirFox recht geben,
je nachdem, was du geschrieben hast.
Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Ach, hier.
Man braucht, wenn man nichts zu automatisieren hat.
Ja.
Also, dem hier würde ich recht geben.
Allerdings bietet sich Kubernetes oftmals auch an,
einiges, sagen wir mal, automatischer zu machen,
weil die Anwendungen eben darauf ausgelegt sind,
dass sie ohne Probleme dort gestoppt werden können,
dort gestartet werden können,
was ja viele klassische Anwendungen nicht so gut verkraften, so.
Oftmals, die auch ein bisschen Jahre auf dem Buckel haben, so.
So von wegen irgendwelche Java-Anwendungen,
die erst mal acht Minuten brauchen, bis sie gestartet sind und so was.
Wann kommt denn eigentlich Season BF20?
Ich weiß nicht, Season 6?
Im Oktober?
Ja.
Okay, Leute, ich geh mal jetzt futtern.
Mal gucken, wann wir uns sehen.
Ich hoffe, also morgen auf jeden Fall,
morgen bin ich auf jeden Fall am Start.
Ob ich heute Abend noch mal am Start bin, weiß ich nicht.
Wir könnten noch mal drei Stunden Baldur's Gate spielen.
Akt 1 ist durch.
Nach, fragt mich nicht, 50 Stunden oder so.
Wobei ich noch ein paar Sachen offen habe.
Mal gucken.
Morgen bin ich auf jeden Fall am Start
und eventuell sollte ich mich jetzt einfach mal nach dem Mittagessen hinsetzen
und YouTube aufnehmen.
Ich glaube, das mache ich.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Adieu.